this is jocko podcast number 314 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening gecko good evening
the machine rolls on
[Music]
that's what happens when your time is
up and you leave the machine is going to
roll on
and that can be
can be hard
on your brain it can be hard on your ego
it can also just be hard because
you love the teams
you care about the boys
and when you leave
you worry about the void
that is there and you think who's going
to fill that void and and you wonder if
you did a good enough job passing on
what you learned
and
that's rough it was that was one of the
hardest things for me when i left when i
got out of the navy
because
my whole life my whole adult life had
been in the seal teams i was full on
institutionalized by the seal teams i
didn't know didn't know anything else in
the world and i couldn't help but feel
that
i was leaving them hanging leaving my
friends hanging that i was letting them
down
but the reality is
that the machine rolls on
and there are guys
that are ready to step up and take your
place and take things to the next level
and do a better job
and carry the torch and take the fight
to the enemy
and uphold
the traditions and uphold the reputation
of the teams and elevate it
and so
because this next generation of
frogmen step up the machine rolls on
and i am lucky enough to have one of
those frogmen
here with me tonight
carlos mendez los
who i figured out checked into seal team
one about a decade or so after i did
i think
but
who upheld
and uplifted the reputation of the teams
while he was in
carlos thanks for joining us man
pleasure to be here
pretty what year did you checking a team
one
january 35 okay so it was like i checked
into team one in 1991.
no fun once it was still no fun when i
got there there you go
uh well we'll get there let's go back
let's go back to where you came from
because damn
i mean it's a weird ride right it's a
it's you gotta you got an interesting
background story so
you're you're not even you're not born
in america no i was born in guatemala
so um
you know
it you know i'll even start before that
um
so my father passed away when my mom was
pregnant with me oh damn so yeah
actually she got the news on the day of
her baby shower
where'd he die from a car accident
yeah
um
so
uh i was born in guatemala to a single
mom obviously
and um
you know
my grandparents
my dad was their favorite
son
so when my mom had me
i was the favorite grandchild
and um they had they had a lot of they
wanted a lot of control over the way she
raised me and it was this conflict back
and forth
and you know when i talked to my mom she
said ultimately that's what
uh
drove her to the decision to to
immigrate to the u.s she's like i need
to get you away from here because i was
i was spoiled rot
from what i hear i was an absolute
terror
and i can get away with it because
grandma was there to protect me
and uh yeah she used to babysit me my
mom would drop me off
in the mornings and it was funny because
the things that you remember
just so weird i remember we would go get
gas and in guatemala you know people
don't have a lot of money so if you
filled up a full gas tank you got a baby
chick okay yeah
so my mom you know filled the gas tank
up and we'd get a baby chick so i
remember i would drive back to my
grandma's house and i would have that
baby chick and we had all kinds of them
you know from all times we filled up the
gas tank
so it was me chasing chasing a bunch of
chickens and chicks in the backyard it's
interesting that your mom
she's got to be a pretty
uh interesting human because you would
figure here she is single mom and she
actually has the this kid you
that is getting swooned over by the
grandparents it seems like a single mom
would be like thank god these
grandparents are here to help me through
this
and
i'm totally i'm kind of sad now right i
got like backup
as opposed to no backup which
you know your dad was dead i mean that's
but she but she just thought oh he's
being spoiled
we're out of here
oh yeah my mom's a gangster she is a
very old school hispanic
um
just very you know disciplined
uh
screw your feelings kind of thing it's
always your fault kind of thing
like i remember any time i got in
trouble she said what'd you do it was
your fault
i'm like everybody else's parents stand
up for them not my mom my mom's like
what'd you do
i know i know it was your fault some way
or another it was your fault so that's
why i was kind of joking around with jp
that i had extreme ownership
at birth yeah basically but yeah that's
what drove her decision to to leave
guatemala and come to the us so how old
were you when you came to the u.s do you
remember i guess you must remember
because you remember
yeah i mean there's you know things here
and there that you remember i i was like
four or five but i do remember
i was in school
uh and i remember showing up to school
not being able to speak english
um
and my mom set me up for total success
and i say that sarcastically because she
would dress me up in like a collared
shirt
everything was had to be like a cause
you know guatemala you dress nice to go
to school you have uniform and now we
were in in uh san francisco
not a nice area either you know um
and so i'm wearing this you know
button-up shirt with some
some docker-type pants that we got at
the goodwill
shirt had to be tucked in and like
these alligator skin shoes because in
guatemala they're they're cheap you know
like alligators can choose so that was
like the thing
and she's like you know guatemala these
are like a luxury
i'm like over here it's getting my ass
kicked wearing these alligator shoes and
dockers and tucked in shirts so yeah uh
i needless to say i ran into a lot of
issues when i first showed up didn't
speak english i'm dressing like a
complete dork
and you know the kids that i'm with are
a little rough around the edges what'd
your mom do for work when she got here
so i remember she worked at
she worked at the school that i was at
so she can keep an eye on me as a
teacher's assistant and then after
school i remember she worked as um she
would clean houses and i remember
going after school we would go to you
know whoever's house and she would clean
it and i would do my homework while she
cleaned and if i didn't have homework
like i would help her out and um
and then i think like twice a week or so
she would go to english
school to learn how to speak english
and i'll go with her there and are you
but you're you're getting uh what's
immersion training at school because
you're just showing up and they're
speaking all english oh yeah yeah yeah
and uh it's kind of funny because when
so my mom's side of the family was
already in san francisco oakland bay
area so that's why we moved there she
had her side of the family there my
dad's side of the family was the one
that stayed in guatemala because they're
actually pretty well off there
um
so she had that support system and i
thought it was it was interesting how my
family was like oh the kids need to
learn how to speak english so the kids
won't make fun of them
and my mom was like i don't care about
his feelings like okay they make fun of
him so what he's not allowed to speak
english at home because he's gonna
forget spanish he's gonna learn english
regardless
but i want him to to remember how to
speak spanish so at home i wasn't
allowed to speak any english your mom is
a gangster huh oh dude she's
she's heartless
and then uh so then you ended up she
ended up meeting someone else or getting
married to someone else right like uh
step dad showed up basically yep so she
actually met my stepdad in san francisco
in uh english school
so he was from czechoslovakia when it
was still czechoslovakia
yeah and his story is is pretty amazing
um
you know when he was in high school so
he was there when it was still under
communist rule
so when he tells a story
uh
you know he was in high school and he
drew a cartoon criticizing communism
and i guess like a week later some some
men
showed up they dragged him out of school
they beat him up and then they told him
hey when you graduate we're going to
send you to the mines and you're going
to die there you're going to work there
for the rest of your life till you die
so he was just like nope not happening
he started planning his escape
and um
didn't tell anybody not a soul
packed his stuff in like this green bag
that he actually still had when i met
him
packed everything he had in there and
and ran away and um he just recently
told me this story too like maybe two
three months ago like the actual details
of how he crawled for days across the
border and somehow made it into
yugoslavia and yeah it's a pretty crazy
story
yeah the the when you're in those
communist countries the amount of in
government inform like
it's some crazy number like 50 of people
are government informants it's a crazy
number it's a crazy number so your
stepdad couldn't have told anybody
because if you tell one person you might
as well just tell everybody and you're
gonna get ratted out and he's already
got the threats of being in the mines
for the rest of his life and dying there
good lord yeah
freaking savages
um
so they end up
getting married i mean is that that the
next phase yeah they they started dating
and um in my head i'm thinking like oh
sweet i'm finally gonna have a dad you
know little did i know he was meaner
than my mom
you know i mean he's a hard hard man i
mean he's you know
communist bloc they grew up very very
hard up there life is hard um
so he was hard on me
so what were you doing growing up what
was uh what was what was a day day in
the life of carlos
um let's say age 11.
oh age 11. oh by that time we had
i'm not sure i don't remember if we had
already moved out to sacramento at one
point you know they were like hey you
know the bay area is just too expensive
it's not a great place to raise a family
and we moved out to sacramento and i
remember we started renting this house
out that had this huge yard well for me
it was huge because i hadn't seen a
backyard
you know in san francisco or oakland
and um
and and he just gave me a ton of chores
like that's what my life so my life was
i come home from school i do chores i do
homework and then after we eat dinner
you know i wash all the dishes i take
everything off the counter wipe them all
down
sweep mop like that was something that i
did every single day and then in the
backyard i always had all kinds of
chores that he had for me
and um i think a lot of it too had to do
with he he worked a ton
like he is
probably the hardest working man i've
ever met in my life like yeah he was
mean and probably growing up i i wasn't
you know i hated him growing up but
now that i i'm i'm all grown up and i
look back like man that guy worked his
ass off
like he did anything and everything he
could do like i remember he used to sell
like
uh vacuums for electrolux uh he used to
deliver pizzas for dominoes pizza
he
finally got into itt tech to become a
drafter so he became a drafter
eventually
uh designing like elevators or something
like that
and then i remember he would do that all
day he would come home he would take a
nap and then he would go back and
deliver pizzas all night long get maybe
like two three hours of sleep and do it
all over again
so
you know looking back now i'm like okay
that's why i had to do so much stuff
around the house because he just he
wasn't around he was providing for the
family
and
when you get to like what kind of kids
are you hanging out with
uh
you playing any sports or anything no my
mom and like i said my mom and dad were
both really strict on me and the only
two things that i was really allowed to
do growing up i remember with legos and
reading
so i would devour any book i can get my
hands on because we weren't allowed to
watch like tv actually i don't think we
owned a tv for a big portion and then
finally when we did we weren't allowed
to watch a whole lot of it
um
they had a subscription to reader's
digest so i would read reader's digest
cover to cover as soon as they came in i
was actually the one that would rip the
wrapper open and i would just start
reading and it's funny because it was
actually the first time that i was
exposed to the teams even though i
didn't know it there was an article in
uh reader's digest when i was a kid it
was something like the hardest school
you know i don't remember exactly what
the title but it talked about
this
gentleman who was in the army saw some
team guys and went to buzz and he talked
about his experience going through buds
but at the time i didn't know what it
was i was just like oh cool story
but yeah legos reading i wasn't allowed
to really play with other kids because
my life was like chores and homework and
my parents were both perfectionist so
you know i would turn in my homework and
if the handwriting was sloppy then i'd
do it over
or like the dishes like if i do the
dishes and like one of them was wrong
myself i'd be like do them all over
dang it
so um that's kind of how i remember my
childhood was a lot of chores um
homework and then kind of just reading a
lot and playing with legos a lot yes sir
all right um
did you end up yeah i think you've
mentioned you had some kind of like
little farm or something at some point
yeah like at least some little animals
running around the house
yeah so at one point you know we got
accepted for this program that was like
for for low-income families where they
allowed you to build your house and it
would offset some of the cost but it
would a lot you know it was like a path
to ownership yeah that's legit and so my
parents both applied for it we got
accepted so for a long time that was
that was actually a big part of my
childhood too for a long time i remember
like going to school and then going to
help at the construction site
my weekends same thing
they were they were spent at the
construction site helping build our
house
and when it was completed
you know
my stepdad had all kinds of stuff in the
backyard like we had this little farm
so we he built like when i say he built
i mean mostly i built
because my weekends were like i remember
my weekends like oh i'm gonna get to
sleep in and i would just hear a bang on
my window like at 5 30 in the morning
and it's him like hey get up it's time
to work
dang
you know so i go out there and we we
built a greenhouse we we had all kinds
of fruits and vegetables
uh we had a compost pile so i remember
digging that hole he made he wanted it
so big and i spent forever i did all our
irrigation so i dug all the holes for
that
and then he got this idea for so we had
all our fruits and vegetables he's like
now we need our meat
so he's like we're gonna you know in
check we used to rabbits
so i remember going to the state farm
like looking at all these different
rabbits and then he's like oh these are
the kind that you can eat
so we bought like a male rabbit and like
two or three females and we started
breeding rabbits
little did i know that was gonna be
that's so that's another chore now that
i had like taking care of these rabbits
feeding them you know cleaning up their
poop and then when i got the poop i put
it in the compost pile and everything
like all the clippings from the grass
and and everything we grew with throwing
the compost pile now i'd have to go in
there and like mix it up and it was
miserable
but then the the baby rabbits got to the
to age
and uh he's like hey your chore from now
on another chore is going to be like hey
you're going to kill the rabbits you're
going to skin them and you're going to
put them in the freezer
and i'm like well i don't know how to
kill rabbit he's like you're gonna learn
today
and he's like well let me know he's like
let me know when you kill that first
rabbit let me know and i'll show you how
to skin it
so i i remember being a kid because i'm
looking at i'm like how old are you at
this point
i'm going to say junior high okay so
what's that like 12 12 or 13 something
like this
around 11 or 12. okay
because i remember being young
because i remember so the first one i'm
like okay i think i think i'm gonna
drown the rabbit right so i grab a
bucket i fill it up with water
and i gotta grab this rabbit and i put
it in the bucket and it freaking won't
die and i'm and now i'm crying i
remember crying because i'm like oh my
god please die just die damn it and i'm
just holding it and just like finally
you know the rabbit dies and i'm just
like oh my god that was the most
miserable experience ever i'm like i'm
literally i'm crying i'm a kid
and so finally i go back and i'm like
okay i killed the rabbit you know
he's like he's like stop crying fifina
that was his nickname for me
which fifa is freaking czechoslovakian
for what it's czechoslovakian for [__]
so um so you know he shows me how to
skin the rabbit and i'm like okay and
i'm not really paying attention because
i'm still traumatized
broken and then he's freaking raised
rabbits
so now he's like okay it's time to kill
the second one and now i'm like i'm
gonna do it a different way
so i i'm like i grab a two by four i'm
like all right i'm gonna hit this rabbit
on the on the head so i grabbed the
rabbit i'm like petting it you know and
then i i hit it but i kind of half-ass
hit it so now he's just like twirling in
my hands and now again i got snot
running down my nose tears and i'm just
like eating this rabbit again like
please damn it just die
and finally after whacking it like a
million times died same thing comes out
teaches me how to how to skin it
and then on the third rabbit something
happened
you know
something already happened twice but
something happened that actually stuck
with me for for today actually all right
so i remember i got this rabbit and i'm
petting it and i'm now i'm talking to
myself and i'm like all right
[__] by the way this is how
serial killers get created
yourself so when i told my wife the
story she's like i get it
but i'm i'm looking at this rabbit and
i'm like you know talking myself up i'm
like pumping myself up and i'm like you
know what
i got to commit
like 100
commit
so i remember i grabbed that rabbit i
grabbed that 2x4 and i hit it as hard as
i could and it was out
and from that point on it's crazy
because even in the teams when i did
something that i was a little bit scared
of or even you know anything i'm like
commit that thought has always come in
my head like if you're scared of doing
something you got to 100 commit or it's
not going to work
and and in that moment i had that
epiphany that's an 11 12 year old kid
so yeah that's my rapid story
so
i you know a lot of times people ask me
questions about
because i got kids and parenting and all
that stuff and one thing i warned warned
parents of you know if you push hard
against your kids
oh yeah they're going to push back and
by the way this isn't just with kids
this is with a seal platoon this is with
a company that's with a business you
start imposing stuff on people
they're going to start to push back
because they're humans and humans don't
like to have things imposed on them and
you can by the way you can impose things
on people permanently but you have to
like crush them and you have to
continuously crush them forever and you
have to be willing to go to that
distance where you crush them which is
not going to produce the type of humans
that you want
so
was there any pushback and well let me
rephrase that at what age did you start
to say i'm pushing back against this
stuff uh
i'm gonna say around my sophomore year
um you know i'm 15
and
um you know like like i said my stepdad
ruled with an iron fist and at that
point i'm like you know what i'm not
scared of you anymore
because his punishments were so extreme
like his punishments were like oh you're
grounded for the weekend it was like
you're grounded for the next two months
and if i messed up it was like another
month and i'm like
dude there's like no light at the end of
this tunnel two months when you're a kid
might as well be like
yeah yeah yeah so um and you know they
didn't let me play sports
so i wasn't hanging around the jock so
guess who i hung out with
i hang out with thugs
hung out with uh people that you know
weren't the best influence on me and um
i got into some trouble
you know um
and i got i got i got locked away in
juvenile hall and
and
so how old are you
uh
15 16 years old and
i remember when that happened because my
stepdad at this point he had actually
just graduated the chp academy so now
he's law enforcement damn yeah he's law
enforcement and i'm running around you
know
little little mini gang banger yeah
breaking the law and at one point i got
caught
i got arrested and i remember the cop
bringing me in and interviewing me and
i'm just like
i don't want to talk because you know i
got that stupid mentality i'm not i'm no
snitch i'm a gangster
so i don't snitch i don't say anything
and he's like hey it's not going to go
little did i know everybody else was
singing like a bird
so um
so it's crazy because i i remember going
to court so they put me away they called
my parents and my parents like leave
them there
like you don't want to come get your
kids like nope
leave them there
and i knew and i even told the cop i'm
like don't bother calling my parents
they're gonna leave me here he's like
you were right
so anyways i'm in court and you know the
judge is like hey do you want an
attorney and i was like no i don't and
he's like are you sure do you know what
you're doing i'm like yep i don't need
an attorney i was like 15 years older to
represent myself for the court
well i was like hey i'm guilty i did it
okay and then he's like so you plead i
was like i plead guilty like i'm not
even gonna fight it and um he's like
check and he gave me my sentence and i
remember seeing my parents and
no expression on their face but i i
could tell like my mom was was
disappointed in me yeah as they they
took me away in cuffs and
and uh had to do my time in juvenile how
how long were you in juvie for
i think
i think a couple months and that's
because they were full and and honestly
i like i was a good respectful i was
over someone saying i made but i was a
respectful kid because of the way i was
raised so when i was in juvie like you
know the correctional officers were like
you're like the politest criminal i've
ever met did you did you start to see
the path that you were going down at
that point and and realize like maybe
this is
the way it's going to end up
yeah so
you know having different roommates
in juvenile hall kind of opened my eyes
and i'm like man i don't belong here
like some of the kids that were in there
like one of my roommates was in there
because
you know he tried to murder this girl
with his friends and they were so high
off drugs that when they tried to dig
like dig the hole to bury the body they
were so high that they they buried the
whole like not even a foot deep and they
put her in there and just put some dirt
didn't realize she was still alive
you know i mean those are the kind of
roommates that i had i think at one
point they put me in with like a kid who
was in there for a hate crime like a
skinhead and then there for hate crime
and you know just being there i'm like
dang i don't belong here and i felt
terrible that my parents
because i knew my parents had raised me
the right way and i'm like man i really
let them down here
um
so that's when i knew i was like this is
this is not what i want to do
so
so was that a
lot of times you people think that but
then you know as soon as they get out
and they get back around their friends
you know was that a good enough like
scared straight situation that you
actually were scared straight uh i
wouldn't say scared straight because now
i'm like okay i did it it was fine um
in my head i'm like i'm i'm hard you
know like i go back into juvie now i'm
on probation and any any little thing is
like an automatic 10 days you go back
so when i got out same thing it was
actually even worse now you know and it
got to the point where i'm like hey you
know what i'm going to do whatever i
want
whenever i want whatever i want whenever
i want and i would wait for my parents
to go to bed and i would just sneak out
of the house
so you kind of got emboldened oh because
you went in there you because it wasn't
really a scared straight thing it was
more like you got emboldened because now
you think hey dude i could juvie wasn't
that bad you know no factor
i'll get out
and yes so you actually got you actually
got worse
so i stopped committing crimes
but i was going out i just wanted to
hang out with my friends honestly
because it was just so strict and where
i made my mistake is this this is around
the time where cell phones started
coming out
so i would you know my parents went to
bed early too and they would put me to
bed like at eight o'clock i'm a teenager
put me in a bed at eight o'clock but at
the time i'm like cool
yeah put me to bed early you know
because the earlier you put me in the
earlier i'm leaving yeah yeah so i would
wait for them to go to bed i would go to
the to the living room i'll grab my
dad's cell phone and then i would roll
out and now i'm the only kid like
rolling around like with a cell phone
i'm like yeah let's call so and so it's
also and so like you know until the cell
phone bill came out i didn't know that
because i didn't know how cell phones
worked yeah because back then this is in
the 90s
oh yeah so yeah so target charge per
minute per call oh yeah it wasn't cheap
either no it was like this is like a
dollar a minute yeah or something
something crazy like that
yeah so my dad blew a casket when he saw
that bill and
long story short it was just this
constant back and forth between him and
i and it got to the point where i told
him i'm like hey i'm not scared of you
i'm gonna do whatever i want whenever i
want like what do you do beat me you
know ground me i'm already grounded for
a life
and so at this time i'm still getting in
trouble for smaller things and my
probation officer was like hey
listen you're like at the point where
we're just going to put you away to your
18.
i was just like oh
dang
and i had a teacher at the time that i
had built a great relationship with um
he was like my
it was like a life skills class way to
teach how like write checks pay your
bills you know stuff like that
and him and i had built a good
relationship and and i don't know how he
got wind of it but he he knew the judge
or whatever and he was like hey you know
he's a good kid
he just
he's got a situation at home where he
doesn't get along with his stepdad and
and the judge is like well if you think
he's such a good kid then you adopt him
and he said okay
and he adopted me and um
and at that point like i think my
stepdad was like at the end of his you
know his way he's just like i can't i
can't handle this kid he's like go and
he signed he signed away and
so are you 16 17 at this point
17 yeah 17. so you're going to be my
senior year your senior year of high
school you're
go gonna
go live with your teacher yeah so i
lived with him and
it was uh what was the deal with this
teacher dude this is like the coolest
teacher ever i don't know so he was very
religious like him and his wife were
very religious they had five kids they
had raised them all to be very like
successful people like they were just
good
people
but in my head i'm like what is this guy
thinking because i wouldn't let some
little thug
move in with me
but honestly when i moved in with him i
was so grateful that i told him i'm like
hey this is your house your rules and
i'll follow them and i didn't give him
like a peep of trouble because i was so
grateful
for what he had done and he treated me
he treated me like an adult for the
first time
you know he was just like hey if you're
going to go out just let me know who
you're with what time you'll be back and
for me that was like
what you know let me go out with my
friend like it was something that i
wasn't allowed to do before
so i was so grateful for that
i'm like dude this is a great thing i
don't want to mess it up and you didn't
hear a peep from me for the rest of the
year
like i was on my best behavior with him
are you getting good grades in school
yeah so actually that's the funny thing
is i actually did really well in school
eve this whole time
and it was funny because i had my
probation officer required like a
progress report
i think so that's how he got a wind of
it because the teachers would look at me
and be like dude you're a good kid you
get good grades uh what are you filling
this out for and i'm like my probation
officer yeah they would look at you
yeah um
and so there were a couple teachers
actually during that time that had a big
influence on i mean one of them's names
bobby pryor he's prior navy vet and he
talked about navy seals too and he had a
big influence on me as well and i
remember him like telling stories about
you know when he was in the navy and he
told me this story that stuck with me
for a long time about these two seals
they were on the beach and they got in a
fight with some biker dudes and they
just got back to back and got after and
he's like these bikers were laid out and
he just talked about how badass navy
seals were but i still didn't make that
connection you know what i mean the
connection being that this is something
you could actually do with your life
correct yeah i was just like oh that's
cool you know um so between him and and
and the other teacher that i lived with
uh
they were a big influence on me in a
different way like i might you know my
stepdad taught me a lot of things that
i'm super grateful how to be tough how
to be you know work ethic but they they
had like a softer more empathetic
uh
mentoring i think that's a better word
they were more mentoring me yeah i know
the um well
here's your your dad saying hey you
can't go out with your friends or sorry
your stepdad saying you can't go out
with your friends etc your mom's super
strict
and it makes you want to not do what
they're telling you to do
when they impose things on you makes you
not want to do it this other dude says
hey you do what you want just you know
just let me know what you're doing and
you all of a sudden want to follow the
rules it's like so such simple
psychology on human beings when you
impose things on people they don't like
it when you give them freedom they're
going to take advantage of it in a
positive way i don't
here's something interesting
like i have grown kids now i have one
that's not grown but my other kids are
you know uh how old 22
20 and 18.
they didn't have curfews
like i'd just be like oh yep cool
oh you know go out this is when they
were 13 years old 15 years old i'd say
okay you know let me know where you're
going
sometimes hey you know what when are you
gonna be back are you coming back
tonight and i just let them do what they
want to do and they all turned out
they they all are fine you know which
what
i mean
like you're like stuttering you then
they all well you know they're fine
i mean they're all good kids i mean
they're all they are actually they're
all good kids they all like you know are
on really good paths in life and i i
never now if you were to step
there was some incidents that took place
along the way some some
things that need some corrective
measures need to be imposed from time to
time if things got a little bit too far
out of line and that happened a few
times but then it was like oh they'd get
back in line and realize and then i
would just give them kind of give them
their freedom back but you know what one
of the key things is that you said is
and i tell this to people all the time
treat them like adults especially when
they're in that age this is this is a
trick too there's a little trick to this
there's an age where oh you're 14 years
old oh you think you can you want to be
you want to be an adult okay cool guess
what adults have jobs guess what adults
do pay bills they pay rent they pay for
their cell phone they pay for their food
so you want to be treated like an adult
you wanna do whatever you want cool i
can treat you like an adult
you owe rent or oh you know you need to
pay for food and all that stuff and they
realize really quick that's a real good
appreciation tool they you want to make
somebody appreciate what they've got
make treat them like an adult and they
kind of they're thinking they want to
get treated like an adult
and then when they start getting treated
like adult they go hey i'm cool with
being a kid for a little bit longer
uh so what'd you do when you graduated
from high school then was it straight to
the navy no no i actually had no
intentions of joining the military so
after high school i started working
construction full-time
um and then on the weekends i worked at
long's drugs on saturdays and sundays
and this was the summer after i
graduated i really didn't know what i
wanted to do and and then you know those
two teachers i talked about they're like
oh so you know you got to start college
i was like no one had ever talked to me
about college and i was like i don't
you know i wasn't excited about it so
they signed me up for college they
helped me out and i started going to
community college and uh i didn't like
it i was there and i'm just like i feel
like this is high school all over again
because you know you're taking the
prereqs you're taking the same stuff so
in my head i'm like i'm not learning
anything right now that's gonna help me
in life
so i dropped out very quickly i think i
was there for like two minutes and i
went back to work in construction
because i was making you know for an 18.
actually i was still 17 because i
graduated on 17. i was making good money
for you know 17 18 year old sure and i
would work seven days a week because i
loved the fact that the more i worked
the more money i would make um so i'm
like dude you mean i can work seven days
a week so i did it um
and it was around that time at long's
drugs they used to have uh
vhs you know still have vhs and and then
we had we rented out movies and so every
friday night i would go and pick a movie
out for myself and that would be my
friday night
and one day i picked up the movie navy
seals
and i went home and i watched it and i
was just like
whoa this is badass and then that's when
i this is these are the guys that mr
pryor talked to me about and that's
where i made that connection
and i'm like
i'm gonna go be a navy seal
and i didn't even know how to swim that
well damn yeah i went into the
recruiter's office i think the next day
and you know i told him i was like hey
i'm here sign up for the navy i wanna be
a navy seal and of course they all laugh
god he was stoked that recruiter goes oh
yeah that was a recruiter's dream it's
outstanding yeah you look like you'd
make a great navy seal
exactly oh yeah this guy totally set me
up for failure like
yeah so he you know
he i went through the process very
quickly because i'm like hey i'm
committed let's do it you know um
and so
i you know i take the asvab whatever and
then he gives me the corpsman rating
he's like what do you think about being
a corpsman i was like what's that he's
like oh it's like a medic when you get
out you're like a registered nurse and
you can have a job i was like okay cool
so when i get out i'll have a skill so
i'll be the medic on the team so i'm
like yeah let's do it
so
um were you in the doc
we did you get some kind of a seal
contract like how they didn't have that
back then but here's the thing i didn't
know anything right so this recruiter
told me screwed me over one i wasn't a
citizen
so you can't be in the teams without
being but you know this this part of it
will come into play yeah
so you know i go off to boot camp um
he ships me off under a corman contract
so i go to boot camp yeah so you're so
just so everyone knows you joined the
navy as a regular navy dude as a
corpsman
and that that gives you no leverage
whatsoever to try and get to buds i mean
very little leverage what year is this
and by the way i i barely got into the
navy because i had had felonies on my
record so i had to get like
multiple waivers and back then you know
being the military wasn't cool so they
were like all right you know because i
told my son now i'm like listen he knows
i got in trouble with this kid i'm like
listen you can't do that nowadays no
i mean you got to have secret clearances
you got to do this i mean you do yeah
yeah they're way more selective now oh
yeah in every branch and for seals for
sure it's easy because there's so many
kids that want to go into it yeah they
can pick and choose exactly yeah so
so i go to boot camp and um they have
the video you know with all the cool
stuff and then i'm like this is it and
like who wants to try out and i raised
my hand i'm like heck yeah this is it
but the problem is i didn't know how to
swim
so we take the screener dude we take the
screen and
i can get from one end of the pool to
the other but i am not what you would
call a good swim like i never took you
know swimming classes like i could do
this right like kind of doggy my way
over and i wasn't scared of the water it
just i just wasn't good
and i failed it the first time around i
was like dang dude what am i gonna do
you know now i'm really stressing
because now i'm like damn gonna go to
the regular navy and i was really really
scared of the regular i was like i don't
want to get stuck on a ship and so
they're like um
my rdc really really liked me you know i
was her yeoman so i had i had a lot of
freedom you know the yeoman cat like
takes all the paperwork so you have
actually a lot of freedom in boot camp
to walk around because i would deliver
all all the stuff where'd you go to boot
camp great lakes
yeah so she was like hey i'll let you
try out one more time i was like oh no
so i go
and by the way everyone and their
mother's trying out there's like 50
people in the pool so i'm swimming and
i'm listening to the times and i'm like
oh my god i'm not gonna make it again
so
i just stood up at one point i was like
i'm done and they're like okay get out
and get ready for push-ups and pull-ups
i was like oh [__] that worked so i got
out so you just cut a lap off your time
like two or two i'm going to say it was
like at least two i was nowhere near
finishing
and but there's so many kids in the pool
did you do any work did you like uh had
you worked out at all go so i was very
athletic yeah growing up but you didn't
play sports so i played sports in high
school oh okay yeah we didn't cover that
oh yeah oh yeah we're coaching high
school so i played you know at pe i
would play football basketball anything
and i would catch on to it very quickly
like coaches were always hitting my mom
up did you play any sports before the
school no i wasn't allowed to so it was
just pe yeah and that's why the coaches
because the coaches are usually the pe
teachers so they call my mom and they're
like hey like your son really needs to
play football i really need to do that
because i was really athletic i was fast
and i was functionally strong because i
did so many chores that i was i was a
very pretty strong kid you know for my
age so
so i was athletic i could do push-ups
all day pull-ups all day you know i
could run
i just couldn't swim so when i got out
you know i crushed the pull-ups and
push-ups and everything else and so i'm
going through the process and then
um
the dive motivators like hey just so you
know corman are not it's not a seal
rating it was the only year that they
did it where for whatever reason they
were like if you want to be a corpsman
with the teams you got to go to the
marines first
so i was like i don't want to do that so
i went to
the office
and i changed my rating to like a
boatsman's mate damn and then i go back
and i'm like hey you know i'm a seal
rating now he's like cool now we can get
you in and then as he's doing my
paperwork he's like you're not a citizen
you can't go
i'm like dang it so i go back i change
it back to a corpsman because i know
what a boatswain's mate is
so i go back i change it back to a
corpsman and
you know they're like hey sorry man we
really liked you but you got to get your
citizenship first
so
from there i went to core school
and then from core school
where
would you end up with the marines right
yeah yeah so about
the majority of the corpsmen especially
if you're male you're going to go to the
marines so they sent me to school called
fmss where they basically teach you how
to be a marine you know they teach you
like marine corps uh like ranks
etiquette whatever and then at one point
they they ask you if you want to go
marine corps regs which is basically you
got to cut your hair like them and if
you do you get like to wear their their
green uniform i forget what they're
called
and they're and like everybody was like
super moto and they're like yeah i want
to be marine corps regs and then they're
like what about you mendes do you want
to be marine corps regs and i was like
no
and like but you get a uniform you get
to wear the marine corps uniform i'm
like i got enough uniforms because
before you had to always carry them
around in your sea bag and you had
inspections all the time i'm like i
don't want another uniform
and it was right around that time where
i met the recon corpsman that was there
um
i mean you just looked at him he just
looked like a stud so i immediately
gravitated towards him and
and then he's like hey just so you know
we're going to have tryouts if you want
to be a recon corpsman at the time they
were like 40 man they're like we're
really hurting we could really use
people
so i go and i try out and i feel the
swim again
but you know he's like hey man get out
do the rest of it and and that screener
was actually legit like it was tough
like it was a ruck run it was like
pull-ups push-ups it was like the marine
corps pft and then it was like all these
different calisthenics with with no
number
you just did it for time and they had a
number that they wouldn't tell you so
like hey you got to do this amount of
mountain climbers and they wouldn't tell
you what it is it was like a day-long
screener
and i passed everything else like i
crushed everything else and he was like
hey i'll tell you what
he's like
you have until the end of fmss to pass a
swim he's like you're obviously you know
athletic you have the physical abilities
to do just can't swim so i'm like okay
perfect and at one point i remember
going in his office and and doing like
the dive physical and getting my chest
extra and whatnot somehow through
conversation i was like yeah i want to
go to buds
he's like you want to do what
he's like i was like i want to go i want
to go to buds eventually like i'm just
kind of doing this you know my time with
the marines and until i could get the
buds
and he grabs my paperwork he like
crumbles it up he's like you will never
be a recon corpsman and he chucked my
stuff in the garbage bro he's like yeah
i'm office
that was it and i was like oh snap yeah
so
then i got orders to uh
2-4 which is a grunt
grunt battalion there in camp pendleton
and as soon as i get there i'm like
really regretting it i'm like dang what
did i do you know maybe i should have
just kept my mouth shut and just gone
with it
and as soon as i get there that's
usually good advice yeah yeah
yeah right and so as soon as i get to
2-4 they're already like hey we're
getting ready to deploy so i basically i
didn't do a work-up or anything i
basically just i think i was home from
maybe a month and then we deployed to
japan
my first deployment and what are you
doing what'd you do on deployment would
you exercises and stuff um so i was like
the the coverage corpsman and you know
my chief knew that i wanted to go to bud
so he he would attach me to like the
amphibious assault platoon or whatever
like where they did all the boat stuff
and otb stuff
so i did that uh it was like they're
corman basically if anybody got hurt i
was the corpsman coverage for that
but during that deployment that's where
i like got really serious about learning
how to swim and i was in the pool every
chance i could get like if if i had the
time i would go in the mornings i would
go to lunch and that's why oh because
there was a guy that i met that dropped
out of buds
and i told him i was like do you know
how to do the combat side stroke and
he's like yeah i was like teach me
[Music]
so he taught me and and that's where i i
got proficient at swimming was during
that deployment
this is still pre-911 so it's just all
kind of training yeah just going on
training missions and big exercises and
so that's a normal six-month deployment
you go on with the marines yeah pretty
uneventful get done with that and what
happens you come home from that so i
come home and then uh
we get a new chief and we start talking
and then he's like hey have you ever
thought about going recon
i was like uh
i was like yeah i've thought about it
you know but i want to go to buds or
whatever he's like hey won't you have
the conversation with this this recon
chief
and so the the recon chief and i start
talking and then he's like um he's like
hey we have a guy here who's not really
working out and we we want to see if you
want to come over here and i told him
i'm like hey i want to be honest with
you like my goal is to go to buds
he's like hey listen no problem he's
like why don't you come over here see if
you like it if you like it stay if not
i'll send you to buds and i was like
okay and then he's like um he's like if
you come over here i'll give you b.a.h
which has an e bam what's the ph
basic allowance for housing but it's
legit
legit money no it could be like 1200
bucks a month yeah and when you're what
were you for yo you're an e4 you're
sort of like maybe almost doubling your
paycheck not quite maybe like
50 of your pay
you're gonna you're gonna make extra
it's a big deal getting that bah that's
why dudes get married by the way dudes
that's why you see 18 year old marines
are like yup get married why are you
getting married oh you met the woman
your dreams no but i'm going to get b8
bh son
they want that
yeah bah
it's a big deal especially in the
marines because in the marines the the
barracks had to be like 95 man and you
had to be like an e5 or above and so i'm
an e4 and he's like bh and some magic
words i'm like let's do it
so i headed over there and uh
and i see the guy that i'm supposed to
replace and the guy looks like superman
i mean he's super tall just jacked and
i'm like i'm replacing this guy
and then you know i kind of like i could
tell that the lpo there kind of saw i
was like oh dang you know i see this guy
and he's like his yeah he looks like
superman right and i was like yeah he
does he's like you know what's his
kryptonite water oh
i mean i guess he he would freak out
during the water evolution because they
had him like tread water with like
they'd do a lot of stuff over there with
water
and
i guess he would just like freak out so
i'm like okay cool
so that's how i ended up there um they
put me right into
my first introduction to them what was
it was an sr
so they were like hey you're going to do
an otbsr
yeah pendleton sure i had just been
there i had just gotten there and there
was a corman there who had at the
recombination who had orders to go to
buds so they're they're like hey can you
take you know carlos under your wing
kind of show them how to pack out for an
otb sr
and by the way i've never swam in the
ocean before so now i'm about to you
know at night get dropped off swim
through the surf zone yeah with uh with
a round loadout oh yeah which is no
enormous
so he's like teaching me how to like
load my stuff out and then i'm like hey
what about like warm weather stuff he's
like this is recon bro
and then by the way this is winter time
and and then um he's like this is recon
bro like we don't take that stuff and
i'm like okay you know it's like check
he's like we take batteries and this and
then he's like i'm like okay got it and
then i'm like hey question how am i
getting this brook through the surf
because it's heavy he's like oh you can
put floatation on it i put a ton of
floatation on my because i'm like i'm
gonna drown
so we go and we do the sr
i make it through the surf zone just
cheer will but i mean i must have
swallowed like a gallon of water going
through the service that was my first
time ever but you know i'm trying not to
be
the weak link
i'm trying not to be a fifina
so we make it through and you know we
change out and we start uh patrolling
and then we get to to the to the place
where we're gonna
set up camp
and then everybody starts busting out
their warming oh yeah they were and i
look around i'm like
damn it
and they're like hey what's up doc like
where's your stuff i'm like where are we
going i was like i thought that we
didn't bring warmies out and they're
like
no way bro like we bring a ton of
warmies out
and i'm just like oh yeah i'm just and
and i'm freezing cold because it's
winter time out in camp pendleton we
just went through the surf so i'm so wet
and finally i'm just like you know what
i i'm gonna volunteer to just watch the
radio all night i was like there's no
way i'm sleeping tonight and so i did i
just
jack jackhammered all night long watch
the radio and would get up and walk
around just try to keep myself warm and
the marines loved it you know because i
volunteered to do watch all night long
for for the rest of this are but that
was my introduction
i was i when i got to the teams i was a
new guy didn't have my bird yet and i
got sent to a comm school out on the
east coast that was run by uh by the
teams
and
i was a new guy and my but my swim buddy
was a new guy two of us
and
we there was a like a six day five or
six day ftx that you went on at the end
of this consequence a two-month com
school was freaking legit it was a great
course
and the chief that was running it
you know i was like asking him questions
because i was wanting to know you know
what would be a good thing to bring when
we're in the field and i said hey you
know a guy you know should i bring like
a sleeping bag should i and he goes if
you're hardcore willing because you know
i was always trying to be hardcore he's
like if you're hardcore willing he was
bringing a poncho on a poncho liner and
i was like well check
i am [__] hardcore yeah and i'm just
bringing i'm punching a poncho liner and
i did
and that's what i went out in the field
with and as we inserted the first night
it was raining as we inserted it turned
to sleet like as the vehicles pulled up
to drop us off and then it turned into
snow it was balls
balls cold
and
on this course you had like a comms
window every
every two to four hours you'd have to
make calms to some different part of the
country
and most guys would like miss calm
windows and that would be you're getting
graded the whole time and if you had the
best grade at the end then you get
extracted early
and so
we
me my swim buddy same thing like we were
we were trying to be hardcore so we
didn't have warmies for [__] we're
freezing
and
we never missed a calm window and the
reason we never missed a calm window was
because we couldn't sleep we're just
just like freezing but yeah that's um
always bring a ground pad and always
bring a bivy sack because that's what i
learned eventually the bivvy sack is the
deal if you've got a bivy sack you can
climb in there and you can pretty much
just gut through some serious [__] yeah
yeah but um yeah that's good that's the
way that's what that's what happens to
the new guys yeah don't believe when
your chief says
we don't bring warmies he's full of [__]
yeah well actually the the recon
corpsmen that were there they were cool
about it because they were like hey we
heard what happened like dude i'm not
gonna say the guy's name he's like he
totally hooked you up
i'm like yeah he did
so
at that point they put me into rip which
is the recon doctrination platoon so
basically it's you competing for a slot
at their at brc which is like their
selection process and that's a little
bonus is it still in coronado it's in
camp pendleton okay so rip is in camp
pendleton what's the one that used there
used to be something corny that's brc
so in rip they put everybody in there
who just showed up to the talent and
you're because there's only 30 slots so
you're competing
so the top 30 guys go to brc
if you didn't make that cut you go
through rip again and hopefully you make
it through the you know you're in the
top 30 how long is rip
um so there's no like real timeline to
it i think it was just like hey you're
just doing it until the next class of
brc shows up
and then they start ranking you and then
you get your your slot
and so you know the corman were like hey
just so you know like you know marines
are always harder on the corpsmen don't
let us down and so i i go to rip
and i'm doing
well on everything except for land nav
i can't freaking land nap to save my
life dude i was just getting lost and i
was really getting down on myself and
and then one day it just clicked
like i looked at the map and i'm just
like
it came to life i get it yeah i don't
know it was just like this moment like a
light bulb moment and from that point on
like i was like land i've got it
so i was able to secure a spot to brc
so i go to brc which is in coronado and
that's where i start seeing like the
buds guys and i'm like dang you know i
wish
i was here but i'm here now and um
you know i did pretty well in brc there
was a guy there named mendoza
and he was not good
at all and the instructors would get us
confused
and so i would be running by and like
hey you drop and i was like okay and
like where's you i heard you lost your
map and this and that i was like that
wasn't me that was mendoza
and they're like oh
like we'll push them out anyways you
know and then finally this guy i i don't
remember if he quit or if he got dropped
but thank goodness because then once he
got dropped i'm just like cool because
he was just messing up left and right
they would get us confused
mendes and mendoza so i i had to pay the
man a few times for his yeah and then
sometimes we're like you know what both
of you
just paid the man how long is brc
if i remember correctly back then i
think it was like two months long
and so you obviously you finished it i
did not i actually got a stress fracture
about
two weeks from graduating
and um you know they they sent me back
to the to the bas with the corpsman i
got x-ray and everything like yeah and
at the time you know they were like hey
how is he doing and like actually he's
ranked number one in the class before he
got dropped so he's like he's welcome to
come back
um
and then at that point they're like hey
do you want to go back and i said no i
was like i want to go to buds
i made my decision that i was like hey i
want to do this like because here's the
thing like if you finish
um
now you owe them time because after that
they sent you a receipt yeah if you
finish then you send you to jump school
dive school and now you belong to them
because they've invested money into you
um it was kind of funny too because when
i went they were like
somehow it came up that i wasn't a
citizen
and they were like oh [__] you're not a
citizen like you actually weren't
supposed to go to brc if you weren't so
they were like let's get you some
citizenship so they they kind of
fast-tracked me and i was able to get my
citizenship and so they're like hey for
the rest of the time here you know we're
just going to attach you to a platoon
uh and so they approved you going to
buds they were like all right that's
what you want to do yeah they were
really yeah they were awesome about it
they i had great leadership there they
were great great like super professional
guys um i still keep in touch with some
of them so hey i'll tell you what we're
going to do till you get orders and you
go we're just going to put you in a
platoon and you're gonna do a work-up
deployment and you just be the corpsman
and then when you get your orders to go
to buds you go so
that's what i did so i got orders to go
to bonds were you worried about this
stress fracture scenario because like
that's all kinds of people get stressed
fractures and buds
um i wasn't because i i i never you know
i was like oh i'll heal up i'm young no
factor yeah so i
got orders to go to buds in
november of 2003
right or 2002 sorry 2002 november of
2002. so where were you when uh 911
happened i was at the recon battalion
but they were like hey i i don't think
we got deployed or anybody from that
battalion got deployed
um
to to afghanistan at that time but that
was still there but you know at that
time i already had
my path so they were like hey even if
you go there you're not gonna go with
the platoon so then would you when did
you get the buds finally
november of 2002.
what you expected
i mean you must have been pretty
freaking kind of ready for it at this
point oh yeah i had i had run with a
rook i had done otbs countless otbs i
was really good at land nav i mean like
i got attached to platoon to work up
deployment with them so i was
i was ready
um
and so when i showed like oh here's the
thing too they they sent me to like a
a like a combat engineer battalion
they're like hey we're going to send you
like you can't be in the platoon anymore
because they're about to deploy
and you know obviously it's going to
overlap
you're going to start buds before we're
not going to bring you home halfway
through deployment so they're like go to
this combat engineer in battalion and
you can work out all day and that's
where i met this guy named captain gwyn
who had like a master's degree in
kinesiology and was all about in the
fitness and when he learned that i was
going to buds he's like let me train you
i was like are you serious he's like
yeah so he got me even more prepared
like we worked out three times a day in
the morning at lunch and afterwards
and then he started teaching me how to
eat properly so when i got to buds i was
i was ready like i could do 30 or more
pull-ups 120 push-ups 120 like i was i
was a machine when i got there
um and your water had obviously improved
oh yeah yeah at that point i've done
countless otbs and yeah it was good to
go and then did you get what you
expected there in buzz any any issues or
anything
so when i got there i'm like you know
everybody tells you oh you got to be the
gray man so i'm like okay cool i'm going
to be the gray man
but by gray man people that don't know
this is just a term to
to explain if you can go to buds and you
can kind of
not stand out that's a good thing
because
there's very few people that stand
there's only might be one or two maybe
three people in the class that stand out
because they're good
but the people that stand out because
they're bad and then once you've got
someone watching you oh yeah then
everything you're they're gonna start
seeing all kinds of things that you're
doing that are jacked up so
one of the
strategies of going to buds is to
try to
be the quote gray man meaning just be in
the middle
finish the stuff don't stand out don't
draw any attention to yourself
and that's a good strategy for getting
through and you would heard i don't
think we had that i don't think that was
a term when i went through uh but i kind
of instinctively well
everyone instinctively knew you didn't
want the freaking instructors to know
your name or your face or you just
wanted them to ignore you as much as
possible so you know you're just trying
to do what you're told and try and you
know yeah try not to stand out and that
was the plan i'm like all right i'm not
gonna shine you know i'm just gonna stay
in like the top 25 percent
but that was not possible because
when i first got to buds you know you're
standing watch when you're waiting to
class up
and um
you know a buddy of mine there and buzz
is like hey let's go out one night you
know let's before we go out so we go out
we party and how old are you i'm
okay yeah 2002 i'm 22. yeah i was like i
was young so i couldn't it was going out
wasn't a thing i could go with the the
bar the the e-club on base you could
drink when you're 18. but i wouldn't
even want to do that i just want to make
it through bud so it's weird to me it
would have been
it's weird to me like having a guy like
hey let's go out to a bar cause i can't
fathom what it would be like to go to a
bar when i was in buds yeah so we go out
and he starts talking to this girl
and then he's like hey bro like i need
you to you know her friend really likes
you like i need i need you to
to entertain her while i'm with this
girl and blah blah and i'm like dude i
got a girlfriend he's like come on man
we're going to be in the teams like
you're supposed to have my back
you don't want to be known as that guy
and i'm like really like you're going to
play that card with me so i'm like dude
i'm not digging you know i'll talk to
her i'll keep her busy for you but i
could tell she she's into me like she
wants
she she wants more and
he's like dude we're going to go back to
their place
and i'm like dude i really don't want to
he's like bro come on you got to do this
for me i'm like listen i think she wants
more than what i'm willing to give
because one i wasn't attracted or two
you know i had a girlfriend at the time
and then um
so i'm like all right dude like i'll go
i'll go back to their house with you
and when we get there
i i see her car and it has a first recon
battalion sticker on it
and i recognize that sticker because
it's a sticker for different parking
lots you had different stickers and that
was like an operator sticker like if you
got to park in the operator parking lot
and so i was like hey where'd you get
that sticker from
she's like oh i could tell she's getting
flustered she's like my my husband
and in my head
this is my out and i'm like bro we
cannot do this we gotta go
i was like i am not doing it now i have
a legit
reason to not go through with this
so we take off we go back to buds
and uh now i'm standing watch on on
monday morning and i get a phone call
i'm i'm standing watch at the quarter
deck with another guy
and i get a phone call from the 618
quarter deck so 618 is where the
barracks are at so you have the buds
quarter deck and you have the barracks
quarter deck and it's it's one of the
guys in my class and he's like hey lois
there's there's some marine here to see
you
and it didn't even cross honestly dude
it didn't even cross my mind because you
were in the
one marines
my buddies is coming here to visit me i
was like that's awesome i was like cool
man what's his name
and he's like hey bro what's your name
he's like he doesn't need to know my
name he slept with my wife
and i was like what i was like i didn't
sleep with his wife and i'm like bro
tell him i could i could explain like
nothing happened like i didn't know she
was married blah blah so i'm trying to
explain and all i hear is this guy in
the background saying like i'm gonna i'm
gonna kill this guy like i want to talk
to him right now
and i'm like dude i'm on watch tell him
i'm on watch and when i get off at noon
i can talk to him he's like no i want to
talk to him right now
and then i'm like fine tell him to come
up to the to the buds quarter deck and i
can talk to him here and i guess tell
them nothing happened like dude i don't
know what's going on in your marriage
but nothing happened
so then my buddy's like dude he's headed
over there and he's he's big he's a huge
dude i'm like
oh my god
so i'm sitting there and then the other
guy that i'm with he's like bro you have
to tell the instructor you have to tell
the od
he's like there's no way you get in a
fight here on the quarter you're done
and the od happens to be a first phase
instructor that day
so i'm just like oh my goodness
so i'm like all right
all right so i go to the first phase
office you know i ring the bell
i'm like you know hm3 mendes here to see
him structure so-and-so and the whole
first face staff is in there because
this is in the daytime yeah it's in the
daytime
yeah this is morning
so i go in there and at that time all
the instructors at buds were like
enormous they're all like six two and up
just jacked out of their minds like i i
swear they do it on purpose for
intimidation factor but at the time they
were all enormous
so i go in there and they're like drop
turd so i'm in the push-up position and
my dress blues you know and they're like
what do you want i'm just like
submarines coming over to kick my ass
[Music]
and they're like would you screw his old
lady or something i was like no but he
thinks i did and they're like
like who's this marine coming over here
to start some [__] like let's go over
there and beat his ass so the entire
first face staff's like yeah let's go
over there so they all head over there
to the quarter deck
and at the time there's like some guys
from like team five that were waiting
there to to screen for another team and
some of them knew each other so like hey
you know what's up what's up like oh you
know some brain coming over here start
some [__] like hell yeah beat his ass
so now i'm like yeah come on over here
you know and uh and so we're waiting and
nothing happens and i'm like dude where
is this guy
and then the phone rings
and it's my buddy from 618 he's like hey
bro i heard what happened i was totally
messing with you
and i could literally oh my god
the blood just like drained from my face
and then the instructor's like is it him
and i was just like i just i i didn't
even i couldn't speak so i just handed
him the phone
and then he's like this instructor so
and so who is this he's like oh this is
airman so-and-so like where's the marine
he's like it was a joke
he's like oh
you got jokes
i got jokes too
he's like you and mendez in your
wetsuits two canteens on the grinder get
some
oh yeah
we got
beat
he ended up quitting shortly thereafter
um
but there was no being the gray man they
all knew my name you were the man oh
yeah and it was just like from that
point on i'd be like where's mendez it
doesn't matter it's a server
oh you passed your uniform detection
that's great hit surf so yeah
so i was like all right well if i'm not
gonna be the great manager to go balls
out i guess might as well freaking legit
so you're not the gray man anymore and
you're going just going hard
is there was there any did you have any
issues in buds yeah i did um
no no buzz
yeah you know during one of the surf
passage um evolutions i had one of the
paddles come across and like break
across my shin so i had this huge bruise
on my shin for a while and i was like
you know whatever and i just kept going
through training and at one point
i realized that
when i would press down on my muscle it
would just stay
and my knee got really swollen i could
barely move it and i'm a corpsman so i
know
i'm like dude these are like um symptoms
of compartment syndrome but i didn't
want to say anything so i made it to the
weekend
and i went back up to the recon
battalion and i'm like hey guys like is
this what i think it is and like i think
it is like do you need to go to the
hospital so i was like well i don't want
to go to buds because i don't want to
get dropped or rolled or whatever so i
check myself into camp pendleton
hospital and then they're like
dude you got to get this drain do you
either have to have surgery you have to
get this drained and i was like
well can we try draining it first and
then like yeah sure so they got this
enormous needle i mean it was thick too
and they just started like draining the
blood from there and they're like
dude you're not gonna be able to to
finish buds and whatever i was like no
i'll be fine
i go back to buds and then the the
instructors got word that i had checked
into to medical up there and they're
like dude we have a medical here
they were cool about it like i thought
they were gonna be pissed but they were
like hey
you know um they they liked me at that
point
uh what phase was that first phase this
was before hell week damn yeah before
hell so it was like the week before hell
week
and then they were like hey no big deal
we'll just roll you to the next class
and i was like you know it was extremely
disappointing um so i got rolled
and then i got rolled into 245
and then
the run
before like the the last day before we
started hell week on a run i stepped in
a pothole
or i stepped in like a you know hole in
the sand and i twisted my ankle
really bad like that thing was
enormously swollen
and then uh i was like no it's fine like
i'll go through hell week and you know
i'll be fine and they're like dude
you're not gonna be able to go through
that and in my head i'm like this is
twice now there's no way they're keeping
me
and um the the proctor at the time
he you know he's looking through my
record he's like
dude you haven't failed a single
evolution here like
not a uniform inspection
not a room inspection
and you know how they are over there
he's like not one i was like no
so you know i had attention detail from
a my childhood
and b you know my time with the marines
like i had attention to detail and i
could follow directions i was like
that was the one thing i could really do
so they were like you know you haven't
failed anything at all they're like you
know what
we're gonna roll you one last time
and then you know last time i made it
all the way through no issues
and then where'd you end up going from
there
uh
so you know you got uh jump school sqt
uh alaska
and then i was a corpsman
so they sent me to uh 18 delta
to to go through the special operations
medic course
which is freaking long too yeah it's a
little over six months if you go through
the full course it's like a year long
did you go through the short course or
the long course yeah so i went through
the short course they asked me if i want
to do the long course
and i said no i didn't want to do that
um
but before i headed out there uh you
know i'd been dating the girl i was
telling about buds and we actually ended
up getting married before i went out
there
and i did it because
when i was going so i had just bought a
house too
so i bought a house around that time in
san diego or not in san diego i was in
temecula because i'm an idiot you know
and i was like oh look at this big ass
house i could buy out here for cheap you
know back then it was really cheap out
there and i didn't realize like how long
that drive was
so um
so i i got married because i'm like hey
i really need the san diego bh because i
spoke to the admin lady at buds and
she's like yeah if you have a house and
you're married and you have you're here
you're gonna get san diego bah and not
north carolina bh which is like
it's pennies yeah compared to san diego
so once again why'd you get married want
that bah
uh
but yeah so the reason i bring that up
is because that was actually a sticking
point when i when i was there it was an
issue because as i was going through the
training i wasn't getting paid at all i
was getting zero like no money no no b.a
nobody okay which is a big deal because
now i got a mortgage
and so i'm digging into my savings and i
had been going you know you know to the
um
to the cadre that were there they have
some seal cadre there as well it's not
like all army guys obviously they have
the liaisons for for nsw
and um
you know i kept going up to them telling
like hey i still haven't gotten paid
still haven't gotten paid and they're
just like oh don't worry about it like
it'll happen like they i just felt like
they weren't concerned about it at all
um and for being honest i wasn't a fan
of theirs like i just i just didn't get
a good feeling from them
and
i'm really digging into my savings and
now i'm running out of money
and i don't know if you know captain
smithers is
so he was the ceo at buds when we were
there and obviously like they knew who i
was because of what happened so you know
him and i had chatted every now and then
and he actually came out and did some
jumps with us and at one point during
one of the jumps like he was sitting
next to me and he was like hey you know
just so you know if you ever need
anything reach out
you see where this is going
so i call bud's quarter deck and i'm
like like you know bud's quarter deck
and i'm like yeah can you please
transfer me to captain smithers office
[Laughter]
so i told him the story i'm like hey i
haven't gotten paid like these guys have
totally blown me off they haven't been
helpful at all blah blah and he's pissed
he's like check so he has commander
zinke call me and commander zinke calls
me and he's like that's that's unsat
that you've gone that long without
getting paid so he calls over to the
school i get paid like two weeks later
but i get brought in and just chewed out
by this senior chief and chief that are
over there and they're like
you know do you not understand how the
chain of command works and blah blah i
mean they were furious
and they're like you know we're gonna
take you to a trident review board we're
gonna drive you down to virginia beach
uh and and have a trident review board
and i'm like dude are these guys serious
so i go back home
and i start calling like my recon
buddies i'm like hey is it cool if i
come back like i think they're gonna
pull my trident and then they're like
dude heck yeah if you if you get dropped
come on
back so
you know i go in there and then
during one of the the the ash chewings
that i'm getting i'm like you know what
i'm like if you guys really take me to a
trying review board this is like what
what you know what consumed you called
cam smithers i was like we're friends
and i was like if you take me this giant
review board i'll call them again
and they were like now they like lost
their minds
and then they're like you'll be hearing
from us when it's time for your trident
review board
and i just never heard from them
they left it alone and i got paid
like two weeks later
check
uh
anything else from 18 delta
well that's where i met neil i met
johnny kim
right on
that little genius
uh yeah so he was in the class behind me
i met johnny kim i was also uh roommates
with uh with the dauber oh right on he
was my roommate
at 18 delta so it's pretty cool going
through with him
um
yeah and then you those guys ended up
coming to team three and you ended up
coming to go into team one yeah so i
actually was initially supposed to go to
team three
and then the corpsman that went to team
one for for whatever reason he couldn't
get a security clearance so they're like
hey you're gonna go to team one now
who's already started their work up and
then you know dauber was the first one
to get orders to team three
um
so yeah
that's how i showed up team one i think
2005. are you just fully amped to be uh
just like beyond and the war is going on
these guys are going on deployment
yeah you get thrown right into a platoon
yeah so i get thrown into the platoon we
start uh they're they've they've already
started their work up um
and it was everything that i thought it
was gonna be
it was awesome the best best job ever i
mean it really was i mean we would go to
you know mississippi for training and do
cqc and then we would go to kentucky for
sock and then we
you know around that time the psd
mission was going on so hey we gotta go
to driving schools
so we would go to driving schools and it
was just awesome like
i loved being around the guys like it
was
it was everything i thought it would be
it was it was pretty cool um
we had some
we had some issues in the platoon though
um
we went through three different chiefs
dang yeah
so the leadership was a little bit of a
dang of a problem
and then i think the last chief that
they brought in there like i don't think
he was really into it he was just like
yeah i'll do it you know
the crazy thing one of the crazy things
i learned to trade at when i was working
at tradet was
look you're gonna you're gonna have some
weak chiefs you're gonna have some weak
officers but if you have some good dudes
in there yeah you'll just overcome all
that you just overcome all of it and
you'll fee you guys are the guys are
going to figure out
oftentimes the seal team succeeds
because of the lower because because the
leadership from somewhere in the platoon
doesn't have to come from the oic it
doesn't have to come from the chief now
those guys can be bad enough that they
actually squash the junior leadership
and that's when you have a platoon that
just falls apart completely
but if the
you know i've seen oics that were just
completely getting carried by some two
e5s in the platoon the oic and the chief
getting carried by two or three good
e5's i've seen that all day long i'm
sure you did too yeah um
but occasionally you'll get a chief or a
oic that
look when they're great that's great
we're all good but occasionally they'll
squash the junior leadership because
their ego gets involved and they don't
want the you know someone else making
calls and it just turns into a total
disaster
um the oic wasn't very well liked either
um
yeah so you guys are getting do you guys
know where you're going on deployment no
because we're competing for where we're
going at the time um and you know
like i said unfortunately the leadership
didn't build good relationships up the
chain of command so even though the
platoon was awesome like we had some
really talented people in that platoon
really really talented people in that
platoon and
um
you know it is what it is this bill
really we were not the favorite platoon
and it was around that time when their
you know the lpos came up to me it's
like hey you know we're short snipers do
you i know you were a marine you're good
at land now blah blah do you want to go
do you want to go to sniper school
and i said uh yeah
um he's like two caveats he's like one
it's army sniper school and two you
gotta go to uav school afterwards and
i'm like yeah fine whatever just send me
yeah it's so it's so weird how your
mentality can be so unaligned with other
people and they're giving you these
quote caveats yeah bro when when we
ended up going to ramadi we were
supposed to go to baghdad and task in a
bruiser and my uh commanding officer
calls me in
and he's like he's presenting this thing
to me like it's the worst deal ever and
i'm like so happy and i'm trying i'm
just poker face you know like hey roger
that storm should we can make some
adjustments and then i was like oh i can
negotiate and i said well we're gonna
need this i'm gonna need some more
people and some more like support and he
was like yeah we can take care of that
totally hooked me up bro but yeah i was
like oh are you serious you're gonna
send us to ramadi instead
let's do this yeah he was throwing
caveats at me i'm like
no problems
in school you know we're gonna send you
basically i'm like
okay you know i'm trying to hold my
excitement yeah let's do it so yeah so i
ended up going to army sniper school and
that was uh that was cool going to army
school and
you know it's
pretty funny dealing with the army guys
so at one point so they sent another guy
with me so they sent two of us to sniper
school
we go out to a bar one night and we see
some of the guys from our class and that
you know at that point they were kind of
standoffish because we were being quiet
too you know we ain't really talking to
people they see us at the bar
and they're like hey you guys are you
guys are the seals in our class right
and we're like yeah like you guys is my
if we buy you a shot
i was like yeah let's do it so i'm like
cool so they buy us a shot and um
i take this shot and it's the most
disgusting thing i've ever tasted in my
life like i want to throw up
and it's it's funny because i so i take
the shot and they're like looking at us
and i'm like thanks guys even though
inside i'm like what the hell was this
so i set it down i'm like thanks fellas
and they're like looking like
dang that's why they're navy seals
so i guess they gave us like some gag
shot that's supposed to like make you
throw up yeah you just both and both of
us were just like normal face all day
yeah no expression like thanks fellas
but inside i'm like what the [__] was
that
um it was disgusting and then they're
just like dang that's why they're navy
did you see that they didn't even flinch
they didn't even flinch
and then um
yeah and then we had another
you know we were back in
back in training and they were like oh
you guys didn't load up in the truck
fast enough or something like that and
they're like oh this one guy was like
freaking out like guys if we don't do
this fast enough we're gonna get beat
i'm like so what if we get beat like
okay and one of the instructors heard me
but he didn't know who i was so he was
just like oh we got we got a tough guy
in the group he's like all right he's
like come on out so he's like push-ups
you know i'm doing push-ups i do
push-ups and he's like okay flutter
kicks
and by the way like i used to do so many
flutter kicks that i got tired of
counting and i would literally set my
timer for 10 minutes straight and would
just do flutter kicks for 10 minutes
straight because i didn't want to count
anymore so he's having me do these
flutter kicks
and i can tell one of the other
instructors like giggling behind him
because the guy doesn't know who i am
he's like oh
you're kind of good at these
and then the instructor's like bro you
know he's a seal right he's like
dude why didn't you tell me i'm over
here like an idiot trying to break this
guy he's not gonna break
and then afterwards like he's like you
won't you want to dip
i'm just like no i don't do it but thank
you
yeah yeah um so you you end up going on
deployment you go to you go to a pacif
yeah paycom deployment
that's where you guys went right yeah so
uh
the majority of the platoon got sent to
guam and then they were like hey if
you're a
uav pilot a sniper or a corpsman you're
gonna go to the pi and that was all
three three for three three for three so
that deployment was kind of weird for me
because i wasn't with
my platoon for the majority of time like
i was literally getting farmed out to
whoever needed me
so i went to tow italia holo zamboanga
there was times where i got attached to
like an oda unit because they didn't
have their 18 delta with them
and um
you know i got attached to them and
there was a point there on the
deployment where i got uh
i got sent on a ship
you know because that's how the i was
getting transported from one place to
another and at the time i had another oi
the way you said that you're like i got
sent on a ship yeah well that was like
the one thing that i dreaded yeah you
know i was going on a ship so this was
like my first ship experience and i'm
there with my my j.o who
is a prior force recon gunny
dad you probably know who he is very
tall dude he looks mean just tatted up
yeah
and so we're on this ship together and
we we go to chow and
he i was like hey sir you know this is
where you and i part ways i got to go
eat with the enlisted you got to go to
officers he's like i'm not eating by
myself he's like you're coming with me
and we're wearing sterile camis so no
name tapes no rank nothing so we go into
the chow hall with the officers and i'm
just like oh no
so i'm sitting there and you can tell
like there's this this surface warfare
officer he's looking at us because he
sees he sees my j.o i mean he's tatted
up yeah we both don't look like officers
so he he's he's looking at us and
finally he gets he gets the courage to
come and sit next to he's like so uh who
are you guys
and then he's like oh i'm lieutenant
so-and-so and this is lieutenant mendes
i was like oh dang i just got promoted
from e5
to lieutenant
so for like the rest of the deployment
or sorry the the rest of the time on the
ship he's like calling me sir and
whatnot and at one point
you know i'm getting off the helo with
my with my sniper rifle because we were
doing like some sniper stuff
i'm getting off the helo with my sniper
rifle and the ceo knows who we are we're
on his ship and he was standing next to
ceo and the ceo was like hey hm to do
you might have done can you mind if i
check out your your sniper rifle and you
just see this guy's look
he's just
you see he's steaming inside that he had
been calling me sir for like two weeks
and he's like turns out i'm an hm2
hm2 man
spot promoted that's like andy stumpf
spot promotes himself to whatever rank
is required
uh
and then come back from that just roll
into another platoon
yeah and how's that one go uh it was
awesome um i had a new oic
new chief new lpo
um
and the this oic was was pretty awesome
he
i remember when he first got there he
set a meeting with me and i'm thinking
oh man i'm in trouble like what's you
know cause up to that point i had very
little interaction with my my oic like
very minimal
and i'm thinking dude i'm in trouble so
i go in there and it kind of shocked me
like he asked me like hey so what you
know what's your family situation like
like how are you doing is there anything
you need
where do you want to go with your career
it was like the first time anybody had
really asked me i was like i don't know
i was just having a great time being in
a platoon
you know and he's like you know i
noticed you don't have a college degree
there's this program you know where you
can get commission we send you away to
school for three years you come back as
an officer is that something you'd be
interested in i was like oh actually you
know i actually had never heard of that
but yeah it's interesting i'll keep it
in mind and you know i always say that
this guy built a better relationship in
the first two weeks with us than the
prior oic had built like in two years
um so it's pretty cool he we
tactically speaking he probably wasn't
the best
um
but strategically he was he was great
because he knew who his subject matter
experts were he's a very humble guy
leaned on them a lot and
you know the same group was was together
again and
it was an awesome awesome workup for me
like i had an even better time in the
first time because i'll be honest like i
was i was disappointed the first time
around with leadership
because i had been exposed to really
good leadership with the marines right i
mean they were like
just absolute professionals and then
when i got to that first
platoon i was a little disappointed so
i'm like okay cool so i that's when i
started realizing like okay leadership
is
you know ebbs and flows sometimes you
get a good one sometimes you get bad
ones and anything in between it's a bell
curve just like anything else when you
go was that when i was running trade it
when you're going through that workup i
don't i don't think you were there yet
yeah i don't think you were there yet
yeah um yeah you know one thing i've
always said is the
the marines have like a tighter shock
group
or like a tighter standard so
like if you have like the best
you know the best seal platoon they're
gonna be freaking off the charts awesome
yeah and but the worst seal platoon is
going to be off the charts shitty
and the marine corps has like a tighter
more standardized group of like hey this
is what this is where they're going to
be they're going to fit in there better
which is nice because you don't end up
with those low points of leadership um
and then where'd you end up going on
on deployment
so um so before deployment actually they
sent me to
to central america for a while because
they had they had us you know a mission
going on down there jset type mission
they're like hey does anybody speak
fluent spanish
i was like i speak fluent spanish so
they sent me down there so i was there
for
for a while let's say it was long
because they switched other people out
like so they were there's like other
guys would go there for two weeks or so
but i was there the entire time just
because i was teaching all the classes
and going out with them and stuff so
i did that first and then um
we ended up getting uh
ramadi mm-hmm
so we're like okay cool we're going back
to we're going to ramadi for friday and
so far i'm like finally
this is it
and when did you show up there
october
let's see my son was born in july so
yeah september october time frame okay
so i was home for like a couple months
after my son was born but it had
mellowed out a lot by that time oh yeah
a lot a lot yeah yeah yeah so what was
the deployment like
so it started off fantastic uh like when
we got there um
we hadn't been in country that long and
i remember we got our first mission
and
uh it was pretty cool because they're
like hey it's it's a little bit outside
of ramadi so where you guys are gonna
take hilos there
so i'm the point man you know i'm
planning out the routes and stuff and i
remember getting in the helo and
and looking around being like whoa this
is legit like this is finally here like
i've got my you know i look around
everybody's got their their nods on
everybody's got their weapons we're in
the helo
and
you know it was a da mission like
it's basically everything that you want
to do and
so you know we get dropped off a few
clicks away patrolling to the target
and um
i see some guards out there with with
aks and and it's the first time like
like literally first mission and i get
to shoot someone right off the bat and
i'm like this is awesome
um
so i'm thinking that's the way things
are you know because i go back to the
base and i'm like i gotta you know i
gotta reload my mags
so i'm thinking this is gonna be like a
normal thing i better go get some more
ammo because you know if it's gonna be
like this all deployment
and then we actually don't do anything
for like a month and i'm just like uh
we suck again
um but then they're like hey listen
there's work to be done but if you want
to do it you got to go to the outskirts
so
we actually ended up packing all our
humvees and going out to tharthar and
then from from there we were at some
small base and we're like living out of
our humvees but but we were working
which is what team guys want to do so
for sure
i thought it was a great deployment you
know when i hear you talk about your
first one
that's kind of how i see this one you're
doing da's all the time you know no one
really got hurt it you know
it was great so
and you get some good experience good to
do those reps man oh yeah like you just
the whole cycle from the planning to the
to the transit to the execution and
things aren't going quite right but you
get them sorted out like you just get
good reps man yeah yeah yep and and as a
point man like it was it was a really
good experience for me
and it's funny because like around that
time
you know
my my oic at one point we something
changed in the plan and then he's like
hey uh
he's like hey we need we switched course
or whatever i'm like checks i was like
let me let me get into my poncho my red
red lens
he's like what are you doing
i was like i need to look at my map he's
like how have you been navigating this
whole time i was like mapping compass
because in the marines that's how we did
it
he's like you don't have a gps and i'm
like no
he's like if you're gonna be my
appointment
you need to know how to use a gps
because i'm like you know under with my
poncho my redlands like looking at my
map and trying to figure it all out and
then
and so i go back to camp and i'm
i bust out my gps it's still in the
wrapper
it's still in the wrapper so i'm reading
the directions and when i
i'm reading the directions to this thing
and uh then i'm like where's this thing
been my whole life yeah
this is awesome
damn that's crazy that was in 2007
yeah yeah
yeah because that's the way i had always
done it in the marines we did a ton of
land nav
and that's actually how i became the
point man because one of the more
experienced guys was like hey bro i
don't know how to land nav
he's like you know atlanta and this was
like my first
first uh uh platoon so he's like hey
you're really good at landing right
you're with the marines i'm like yeah
i'm pretty good at it he's like you
wanna be a point man i was like heck
yeah so that's how i became appointment
but no one knew that i was just going
off my campus my compass in mountain
until then and then when i discovered
that gps man it was a game changer yeah
especially by that time because by that
time in 2007 it was dude like one of the
you had them on your wrist yeah put them
on your wrist so that's what i had i had
the little garmin one i was like man it
even goes on your wrist i'm like this is
amazing it's freaking ridiculous and
then i started carrying two of them
around like one in here and one in my
pocket just in case that one broke down
because now i really liked it so i'm
like i don't want this thing breaking
down on me hey what up that story with
the s vest
so um there's a couple actually so the
one um that you know we always talk
about with complacency we had there was
like a drone
that had
watched some guys like planting some
ieds in the road and followed them back
to their house and
they're like hey you guys are going to
go hit this house like cool so our
platoon was tasked with hitting that
house
and when our you know my platoon gets
there they're like oh
it's kind of odd because there's like an
old man
some women and children like it's kind
of odd
and you know as we're on target or
whatever um we start finding some like
propaganda we started finding like some
small stuff but nothing huge
um and we'd been on target for i'm going
to say
at least like three four hours so we
were there for a while like we got
pictures of guys like sitting on a couch
and and by the way it's like a painful
story to tell afterwards because you
know
you like to think that you're
professionals and
it was definitely a slap in the face
like whoa it's really not over because
because leading up to this like how many
ops did you run at this point we'd been
there for a while so you so you were
kind of we were in a good rhythm you
were getting the reps but the reps start
becoming routine yep and we were on the
outskirts too so like
this this house was out in the middle of
nowhere it's not like in ramadi where
it's like a very dynamic environment
where everybody starts coming out and
and they know you're there
um
so anyways so we're doing ssc in one of
our guys so wait so you hit this target
it's in the middle of vehicles yeah yeah
so you drive vehicles up you hit the
target now you've done this a bunch of
times you get the target cleared
no contact when you hit the target
the people that you find on target is
sort of
the typical sort of people that you're
gonna find old man a couple women some
kids
the houses looks like all the other
houses look like so
in your mind you're probably thinking
this is probably probably nothing here
yeah absolutely and we had to have
targets like that as well and you're
there for three hours doing ssc yeah
because we started finding stuff so like
guys actually had their helmet and they
were like picks and shovels and stuff
okay so like we were actually like
breaking down some walls okay we found
some false walls and stuff and okay so
so suspects so as you're searching it
you're like oh this is some propaganda
we need to go a little harder yeah now
we're going a little bit harder we find
more stuff
and so but at the same time there's been
no
no bad guys no so you're just really
just doing an intel recovery at this
point yeah yeah which means your guys
are kind of chilling out a little bit
very much so they're sitting on couches
yeah
i actually have a picture of that but
so anyway so one of our guys goes into
one of the rooms and lifts a rug up and
there's this um
there's something on the floor that
that's a little different color than the
rest and you could tell it's kind of
like a door or something so he calls the
eod guy over he said hey come check this
out you know make sure it's not
booby-trapped
and he's like no we're good and i think
we're good let's open it up
so we open it up and there's there's a
bunch of dudes down there i think it was
like 13 to 15 dudes down there and the
first couple had like suicide vests on
guy chucks a grenade up it hits our eod
guy in the chest
they dive like behind some furniture the
the grenade went low odor
so
you want to talk about someone looking
out for you it was old you know um so it
didn't blow up to its full potential and
um the avalanche call came out because
they saw they saw the s vessel on the
dude so avalanche everybody runs out of
the house
and as the last dude runs out
you know our humvees are already
ready to go and as soon as the last dude
last man out it was like 50 cals like
boom boom boom and we don't know if like
a 50 cal hit someone's vest or if the
dude clacked himself off but
the house blew up
the house blew up and
some of the guys were were still alive i
guess that were still under even that
even after that explosion
so guys are coming up some guys left
their helmets and nods inside the house
so some guys got no nons i think a
couple weapons were left in there as
well
um
yeah as a matter of fact i'll tell you
the some of the stuff we recovered
afterwards but anyway so yeah
we're laying down fire
and um
at one point a rocket is shot and it
hits like five feet from our humvee so
we're like hey we need to back out we
need to drop air on this thing
so we we'd back out we dropped air on it
actually dropped a couple bombs on it
and then uh you know afterwards when we
go and recover stuff you could tell that
these these guys that that were there
they weren't
they were they were foreign fighters
they were different than some of the
other guys that we had come across
but we recovered some of the nods that
we left in there we recovered um one of
the weapons that we had left in there
and it's crazy because i guess one of
them must have picked the weapon up like
our rm4 and started shooting with that
m4
and when we picked up that m4 uh at the
front of the barrel you can tell that
the 50 cal round had gone through the
front of the barrel damn out the back
blew this guy's head off and then we
found this guy's head like 50 yards down
down the road but
it was crazy so i mean you know we have
a picture of the gun like with a 50 cal
so
doing that uh report on all the lost
stuff
that stings
were you the lpo of the splatoon oh no
no i was just uh just the door kicker
yeah oh that's right you said you were
the point man yeah yeah i love being a
point man
so that gets your uh that that snaps you
back into reality yep yep
so um
yeah
it's completely yeah you said there was
a couple as fast stories
yeah so the the other one was i guess
they were uh they were smuggling some
s-vests in i forget from where it was
you know when you're young you don't pay
attention to some of the details that
that are passed on
but they were they were importing some
s-vests
um
and at one point the the iraqi police
pulled this guy over who they thought
could be one of those guys that was
smuggling as fest so we take the vehicle
and we we rip it apart completely and
behind the glove compartment we find an
s vest
and so our eod guys take it out and then
they're like hey um
let's make it inert and let's put it
back and let's see where he goes and
then we'll catch him and his friends
so they do that they make you know they
they make the vest inert we put it back
we give the car back to the to iraqi
police and at that point you don't know
who's you know who's who
they're all corrupt you know there's
people
that have infiltrated
all forms of government police so we
didn't tell them what we found we're
just like hey we're good
so they're like okay cool so they let
the guy go and of course he goes back to
his house
and at this point now we're being
mandated to bring you know the iraqis
with us because for a while
from what i could remember we were by
ourselves
like just us
at this point like okay so anyway so we
end up hitting this house and old boy
has his vest on and he's like trying to
clack himself off
but it's inert
that's awesome and he had actually two
switches like he had a primary and a
secondary so you know he's yelling out
you know
he's like click and he's like oh crap
and he's like click click trying to do
the other one and
how's that working out for you homie
well he's got no head now you know
good stuff man and no one got hurt on
that freaking though where the uh spider
hole was huh no damn it's like i said
that's about as good a deployment as you
could do a lot of work and no one got
hurt
you get done with that and then is that
when you come to trade it
yeah so i come back and
they're like hey you're going to have to
go to trade it and i'm like i don't want
to go to trade it you know
are you an e6 now i'm an e6 yeah yeah i
just made e6 on that deployment actually
so um
you know i come back home i'm i'm having
some personal issues um you know with
with my wife at the time
and um
you know instead of
trying to work things out and
be a good husband
which you know i look back on
i could have done a much much better job
of you know i look back at that marriage
i'm like hey you know that's 100 my
fault i wasn't a very empathetic person
um
marriage is tough thing and it's even
tougher when you're young and that you
know it's even tougher when you married
a teen guy who's gone all the time and i
didn't think about that you know i'm
just like you know she moved right from
her parents house to me and i'm just
like i don't understand what you're
complaining about
anyways there's a lot of tension between
her and i and she served me divorce
papers
and um
instead of you know trying to take a
knee and work things out what do i do
they're like hey uh there's corman
needed for this afghanistan deployment
and i'm like i'll go
so i end up volunteering for for a very
short augment
before i go to trade it and they knew
that i didn't want to go to trade so
they were like hey you've got some time
here team one before you check in to
trade it cool that was kind of like
you know my gimme so they're like cool
go do that
and so i come back from that deployment
and then that's when i check in to trade
it and um
that's where i meet jp danielle
and did you go straight into uh
straight into salk straight into cqc
yeah so
back then the the the senior enlisted
of the assault cell he would like
interview guys
to go to assault because he was like hey
if you're going to come to assaults like
we're screening you
and so i remember him coming up to talk
to me well i was still at team when i
just got back from deployment so like
yeah you're going you're going to
assaults
so i ended up going to salk
but
you know
being the team guy i was i was like can
i go to cqc too and like yeah sure you
would yeah so i was doing cqc trips
south trips and it was it was pretty
cool and uh
you were there
that's when you were there and then jp
was the lpo at the time yep yep yeah
what did you learn in uh sitting there
teaching
you know so
now looking back i always tell people
that trade it was actually the biggest
learning experience that i ever had
because
it's like the ultimate leadership lab
because you get to watch two different
styles of leadership go through
and you're you're completely detached
you have zero emotion and invested into
that whatsoever so you can armchair
quarterback that stuff all day long
um
and it was where you know i started
realizing the the difference in
leadership
because if you think about it the talent
is for the most part spread out pretty
evenly you're gonna have some good some
good guys you can have a handful of new
guys you're gonna have some e5 pipe
hitters you're gonna have some couple
slugs like the boys are gonna be pretty
consistent most of the time yep you're
gonna get that so yeah it all it all
boils down to just how is the leadership
how good is the leadership and if
leadership's good platoon's gonna rock
and if the leadership sucks
we could have some problems yep so
that's when i started seeing that
you know um
yeah training is the same and i was like
okay it really depends on that
leadership how they're gonna do and it
was really cool to see like the
leadership that did well
it was simply because they were humble
like you could just tell their attitude
right off the bat like they're like you
know when you give them you know
criticism or critiques or whatever
they're like got it got it whereas the
platoons that did terrible they were
just like you could just tell they had
attitudes about hearing anything
any feedback that you had to give them
and it was very blatant like the
difference between the the platoons that
had humble leadership and the platoons
that just
did not
i would like take this to the nth degree
in my own head because i always wanted
to make sure
that
hey what am i doing am i doing a good
job of getting through to this
individual leader right and if it seems
like this leader like maybe they have a
big ego and they think they're a badass
you know what i don't care i i always
wanted to make sure that it wasn't me
that it wasn't my end i was like okay
you know what the guy's got a big eagle
it's okay we want guys with big eagles
like hey you got to have a big ego let
me rephrase that there's nothing you
can't expect seals to not have
some kind of ego like hey i know how to
do this some level of confidence right
you like so it's okay i get it you know
you you think you're a badass cool i
don't want to work for someone that
doesn't think they're a badass right
cool i'm good with it okay let's move
forward that
but man
you'd get these guys that occasionally
again most most of the most of the
leaders are like cool like we're down
occasionally i remember i remember one
time we had this one leader coming
through salk
and i talked to our
civilian that worked there who was a
prior you know seal he was actually my
my tu sea when i was between commander
and i said hey bro man just can you do
me a favor just check me on this like
just look at this guy's face when i'm
putting out word and just give me i go
because it seems to me
like he doesn't want to hear anything
from anybody i just want to make sure
i'm not totally off base but can you
just check him out
and so sure enough like as i as i'm
talking you know the guy be sitting
there with his arms crossed and and and
again i'm just saying
i'm not even like saying dude you're
totally jacked up i'm not saying
anything like that i'd say something
like
hey man do you ever think about maybe
you know putting some vehicles over here
on this target and you can see the guys
like arms crawl i'm not
i'm just offering a suggestion you know
and the dude arm cross and yeah we get
done with that debrief and
that civilian comes up to me and he's
like bro this guy's freaking crazy and i
said okay i just wanted to make sure
because it just
i guess the reason i'm saying this is
because the guys in trade
the guys in trade at the attitude of our
guys in trade was just to try and help
out our friends that are in the teams
like that are in a platoon that was the
attitude the attitude there's no like
hey
i know how to do this you don't there
was no
matter of fact i wouldn't allow that
kind of [__] if we had instructors like
that i would freaking pull them aside
because our instructors realized like oh
we're
these guys are our friends they're our
teammates they're getting ready to
deploy
we need to do our best to help them out
yeah and and and a lot of those guys
know as much as what we know right so
you got a guy that's got a bunch of
experience
bunch of deployments they know as much
as we know so cool we're not attacking
them we're not talking down to them
so
my point is if you have your friends
that are trying to help you
and you
reject them it's really really bad
it's really really bad it's it's
horrible actually it'd be such a bummer
to see it'd be it'd be such a bummer to
see
because
literally like every guy at tradet was
just hey these are my friends that i'm
trying to help and
if
why aren't you open to us helping you
please like we don't want you to get
hurt man
so
ah yeah good times this is freaking um
great place to learn
yeah and i was like i did that luckily
when i was at seal team one as a e5 i
worked in our training cell which is
when the the teams used to train
themselves and so i got to do the same
thing when i was young and that's where
i learned the most of my stuff was doing
that again sitting back detached
watching guys go through platoons we
used to run the sqt classes in at the
team yeah so that was really eye-opening
too because now you had the young
officers
and
you'd watch them and think this guy
can't make any decisions why can't he
make any decisions oh it's because he's
shooting his
weapon right now and he shouldn't be
give him a two by four give him a stick
let him get off his gun and he'll figure
it out and then you actually learn how
to do that for yourself so
yeah if you really want to learn
something it's really advantageous to
have an opportunity to teach it as well
yeah that was also where i learned how
to like brief and
not not i wouldn't say public speak but
you know like when you're talking to
team guys yeah you better be squared
away yeah because they are chomping at
the bit oh yeah to like sense any
weakness
or
anything that you say that's maybe not
tactically correct so i it's where i
learned to be very deliberate about the
way i spoke
in public and debriefed yeah and if you
don't if you don't have anything that's
smart to say don't say anything and if
you have a thought
that you haven't thought through either
think through it or present it in such a
way that
it's not
like an aggressive attack
that's
absolutely true you know you're no seal
platoon you don't have to be traded
you're in a seal platoon and you
disagree with
someone else
what are the chances that you're 100
right the chance that you're 100 right
are almost zero
so eventually probably
two weeks into my first platoon i
realized oh
i'm very seldom going to be 100 right
why don't i present ideas as if
they're an idea not some perfectly
formulated perfectly constructed notion
that is 100 true because there's so few
things that are like that
yeah
even the mo like i talk about in
leadership strategy and tactics
uh the the oic that i had that was
awesome he knew more than all of us
combined
and he would present ideas as if they
were suggestions and ideas and he was
always open to changing those ideas if
somebody said something smarter
so you get to see that stuff over and
over again that's what that's what's
crazy though you when you're working at
trade as you see a platoon tonight
do three four five runs
another platoon do three four five runs
and then a few weeks later you're gonna
see two other platoons with a bunch of
different leadership do the same runs
basically the same runs with the same
people
and the variable as the leadership and
then a few weeks after that you get to
do it again and again and again and
again and you just start to see what
works and what doesn't work and it's
real obvious after a certain point yeah
my learning curve was very steep there
how long did you trade at
so let's see i got there in 2008
um
and i think around
what 2010 or so it was it was like my
time to rotate out but we had gotten a
new chief in
and um
so it's time for me to go do my lpo but
the new chief that came in i really
liked him a lot just just an awesome
awesome guy and then he was just like
hey can you stay at trade it a little
bit longer and then be my opio when it's
my time to go because i'm not going to
be here very long
he's like i want you to be my opio i'm
just like dude i want to deploy man like
that's a long time he's like okay how
about i send you on another augment
i'm like i want the full one this time
so we're like bargaining here i was like
i want a full deployment he's like
okay you got it so i went uh
back to afghanistan
for for another augment uh it's part of
the deal
nice
and you're getting some good operational
experience on your augments oh yeah
going over there yeah absolutely living
the dream
yeah it was it was really cool um
just to see you know watch a different
team do do different things and
um
yeah i learned a lot i learned a lot
from
it was the first time too where i kind
of heard the tl like during a gun fight
like just
how calm and collected they were it was
just like as if nothing was happening
and then i remember that thinking about
that in my head like i want to be like
that
you know like okay cool that's how i'm
supposed to be
you know
so yeah it was a really good experience
again um
and because you know my skin tone i was
able to to help them out in ways that
you know maybe some of the other guys
couldn't so some of the targets had to
be done like during the daytime
so we had to like drive around and like
milk trucks or something and because you
know i could fit in with the popular
side just get in like the passenger seat
and be the navigation guy so you're back
to being a point man yeah but yeah
like a local populace and you're able to
pull that off yeah and that's also
because yeah so halfway through the
deployment like hey we need we need lows
back like get assaults and then i was
like hey they want me back and then the
team leader there was like let me call
them it's like actually we really need
him over here so they let me stay the
rest of the time freaking beautiful yeah
uh but you end up did you end up
did you end up then going with your
chief in trade to be his lpo
no so around that time
they sent johnny kim over to assaults
like just very temporarily because he
was on his way to um go to school so he
got picked up for this this program
where the navy picks like two people out
of the entire navy mm-hmm
and they sent him to go get something
somehow johnny kim slid through the
cracks
yeah right
so he's like explaining this this
program to me um where basically you
know the navy pays for you to go to med
school afterwards and it sounded like a
good deal and at the time
you know i was feeling really guilty i'm
like dude i'm just been gone a lot and i
was like feeling like i wasn't like the
best father to my son even though i
tried to spend as much time with him as
possible i always had that guilt and
then
there's a part of me was like you know
what maybe i should get like a normal
job and be there for my son
so on a complete whim like i put in my
package for that exact same program i'm
like dude if johnny kim is getting
accepted to this thing the chances of me
getting accepted are like slim to none
and so i'm getting ready to go back to a
team with with that chief to go be his
lpo and then i'm i'm flying back from an
assault trip and then he's like hey did
you see the result and i'm like for what
like i literally
completely just i applied and just
forgot about it like dude you got picked
up for that program
i'm like are you serious
he's like yeah
so i was like well i guess i guess i'm
going to school
freaking crazy go try to be a doctor
there was a time period
and it was this this was the time period
where i'm not kidding seals had a really
good reputation in the world you know
and certainly in the navy and i mean
guys we're getting picked up left right
and center for this kind of stuff yeah
so
i mean
that's freaking crazy and awesome yeah
so what's funny is you know like i said
they picked two people a year out of the
entire navy and the other guy was a team
guy too
yeah that's my east coast that's my
point like that's crazy right yeah but
at that time man we
like the seals were just doing a lot of
good work and i mean
i'm sure that when they looked at your
record like seriously they looked at
your record and
compare that to the other applicants i i
bet it wasn't even really that close
just because of the nature of what the
seals were doing at the time yeah
so but did you have any intention of
like going to medical school for however
long that is so i thought i did
you know so are you a year behind johnny
yeah okay so you're you're behind johnny
and johnny went to usd so i went to you
went to usd just because i'm like hey
i'm just gonna do what johnny did
so um so for we had to go to like that
that officer school in up in rhode
island so
in january of 2012 that's when i left
trade it and we went to rhode island
and that's where you learn how to be an
officer do you get commissioned up there
no you just go you don't school yeah you
just go to school you don't get
commissioned until you graduate from
school
but that's actually where like you know
they're like oh you gotta have blue
cammies i'm like i don't own any blue
candies yeah
and what's funny about that so
i didn't know so they have the you know
the big blue jackets
and those things are expensive they're
like 350 bucks and i'm already buying
all these uniforms that i didn't have
right because i don't have any blue
stuff and either because you're gonna
have to go to rotc
yeah is that what you're gonna have to
do yeah afterwards but you don't have to
wear blue but you had to get those blue
candies for
the knife and fork school up in rhode
island correct got it so
my but the other team guy that's there
with me you know we go there and he's
he's cheap too so he's like dude i won't
buy this jacket i was like i don't buy
it either i was like screw it let's not
buy it you know i don't need no jacket
you know even though it's rhode island
in january
so
we form up yeah we form up and i'm in my
blue champions and he's not blue cammies
and and you know the chief the chief
who's like the
rdc or whatever it's called you know
he's like oh how come you guys don't
have jackets i was like well you know we
didn't want to buy them because we're
literally going to have them here we're
never going to use them again and
they're really expensive he's like well
we're all uniformed around here so they
make everybody take their jackets off
and it's it's freezing cold
and then um he's like we'll keep doing
this until you guys buy jackets
and i told my buddy don't you dare buy a
jacket
and he's like okay cool and we were
freezing cold yeah but we would just sit
there and be like we're not cold but we
were we were dying sometimes and got to
the point where they're like you know
people started crying in the class like
literally like oh you know we're
freezing cold so they're like all right
change into your khakis
i was like okay i'll buy the jacket for
the khakis i might use that later on
so you get done with that and then you
go to
you go to usb usd
university of san diego you're going to
be doing the same um
whatever the same thing johnny did yeah
trying to get your pre-med knocked out
yeah
how'd that go for you
not well
i'm not johnny kim
um i'm i'm miserable you know i'm taking
like 18 to 21 units a semester um
i really didn't enjoy the classes i was
taking it's like chemistry biology just
stuff that was so boring to me
and then to top it all off i'm doing
parking services because you know usd is
a private school
and the navy only pays like i think it
was like
i don't i shouldn't say only they pay
10k
and the tuition at usu is like 40k a
year like 40 something k a year so
they're like hey if you do parking
services it'll pay you off the rest of
your tuition so it's a good deal like if
you really break it down
the amount of hours that you work
it's a really good deal so i'm driving
around this this car giving people
tickets at usd and bad karma dude
yeah
well i almost you know almost got into
this big altercation at one point so
you know that so this other team guys
you're the worst ticket guy to mess with
imagine that you think you're getting a
figure to argue with some random ticket
dude and it's freaking loves bro
well it's you know it's funny it's like
if i have to hear you know do you know
who my dad is one more time i'm just
like bro i don't know who your dad is
i'm really sorry but you know you're
parking in the handicap spot yeah but at
one point um
so the parking so it's me and another
team guy so that the the other parking
services kids you know they actually
their normal kids they won't go into
school and they're like oh if you guys
want to get a lot of tickets you got to
go down to this area right here and it
was like where the football field or the
base the uh baseball field was you know
by the gym you went to usd right yeah so
you know what i'm talking about so my
buddy i didn't do ticket parking
i used to i used to put my bike in my
station wagon and just
i would park off campus and just bike
wherever i needed to bike home like back
to my car and drive home yeah so at one
point you know i we go down there and
it's like
it's like the jackpot of all like
violations like we got because we were
having trouble meeting our quota so this
other team guy and i you know the other
parking service kids are like oh if you
go down to this area you get lots of
tickets so we go down there and we're
like oh heck yeah dude there's all kinds
of violations down here we met our quota
super quick
and at one point i come up to this car
and i you know you gotta punch in the
license plate to give him the ticket and
it was like do not let like call the
office immediately if you see if you get
this license plate no kidding yeah so i
call and i'm like hey this thing came up
on my little gadget and they're like do
not let that person leave they have like
nine unpaid tickets or something like
that it was an insane amount i'm like
what do you want me to do
like we'll park your cart behind his car
until the tow truck gets there and do
not let them leave
i'm like is that legal are we allowed to
do that
and uh and they're like yeah so i'm like
okay so i parked my i parked my car
behind this car the other team guy i
don't know where he took off to like
he's gone
he must have been finding like lots of
tickets and so i'm sitting there i'm
waiting for the tow truck and now i see
everybody getting out of football
practice
and the guy's car
the the car who's you know i'm parked
behind the owner comes and it's a really
big dude you know he's a football player
pretty jack dude big dude he's like
hey you need to move your cart
and i was like hey bro there seems to be
a problem like you know with your ticket
stuff
i'm like they called the tow truck but i
think if you call them you know and work
something out he's like
he's like move your [__] car
i was like i can't you know they told me
this and and now it's starting to become
and i'm really like trying to be like
hey bro like listen i'm like the low man
on the totem pole
and now the rest of the football team is
coming out and now they're getting fired
up and now i'm sitting there and i'm
like where the hell is this other team
guy at it doesn't matter how good of a
fighter you are there's a bunch of them
you're gonna get your ass kicked
so and then the guy's like move your
cart now i'm gonna beat your ass i'm
like listen bro i really don't want that
but listen if you put your hands on me
i'm telling you right now i'm gonna
defend myself and at that point i'm
thinking dang it man this is really
gonna happen
and some guy comes running through them
all and then he's like hey
do you know who this guy is
and i'm like who is this guy yeah who am
i like what does this guy think i am you
know and then he's like he's a freaking
navy seal
and then you just see their attitude
completely like oh i'm really sorry sir
like i didn't know you know i and i was
like hey bro it's totally cool like you
know i'm pretty sure if you just call
you can work something out turns out
this guy was the running back with a
prior team guy oh no [__] and he knew
that the parking services guys were
other team guys that were trying to you
know pay for the rest of their tuition
so he saved me that day because i
probably wasn't going to go down very
pretty for me
and then you eventually just change to
you change your major and you get out of
the medical program
yeah so at some point i'm just like i
took a finance class as one of my
electives and i'm like man i really like
this and i really miss the teams i don't
think i want to do this medical thing so
i changed my major without telling
anybody and then when they're like oh so
where are you going to go to med school
and i was like oh about that
uh i'm actually i want to go back to the
teams if that's okay so i want to finish
my degree and go back to the teams and
they were livid damn they're just like
teams they're like no you're you're
going slow you're going to go be a
surface warfare oh my god so now i'm
just like
i don't know what to do so you know i
make some phone calls and they're like
that's stupid you're not going to go be
a slow you're coming back here the only
the only problem is you're going to have
to go through the process just like
everyone else so i have to take the
screener
do an interview
i'm like yeah that's totally fine so
i do the screener i go do the interview
and one of the interviewers is one my
old co from team one and he knows who i
am you know
um so i'm thinking oh this is gonna go
great you know and at one point he asks
me
he's like hey so what are you gonna do
if you don't get picked up for for
special warfare
and then um as an officer you know
and i said i was like well
i am just gonna give up my commission
and go back to being enlisted
and you just see everyone's head just go
and at that moment just seeing the
expression on their faces i was like oh
man i said something i wasn't supposed
to
and you know
because you're supposed to say hey i
want to be an officer no matter what
yeah and
and he was really cool about it he's
like listen lois he knows who i am he's
like i'm gonna give you one more chance
at this okay i'm gonna give you another
crack at it
that wasn't the best answer
and then i sat there and i'm like dang
it i might have messed this up so i sat
there for a minute and just thought
about it and i'm like you know what sir
i know that the the correct answer that
you want to hear is like uh if i don't
get picked up for this i'm going to go
be the best swoe or the best submariner
officer on the planet and then i'm gonna
make my way back but i'll be honest with
you i don't wanna do that i was like i
just wanna be in the teams and whether
that's as an lpo a chief or as an
officer i was like that's why i'm doing
this i miss the teams i want to go back
and he's like that's the answer you want
to go with i'm like yes sir because it's
the truth
and then he's like
it's a bold move don't know if it's
going to work out for you i was like
but yeah eventually i got picked up so
um
back to the teams
so where'd you go what team
so
i was originally supposed to go to team
five
and that old uh chief that i was telling
about the one wanted me to be his lpo
and then the master chief who was the
sca at assaults they're they're like hey
because they came to my commission like
were you going i was like oh i'm going
team five they're like no you're not
you're coming to team three boom and i
was like whoa
you know and they're like trust me we'll
make it work so some trades were made
like they gave up a couple of their jo's
send them to five and whoever the j.o
one of the jails was in the platoon
because they had already started workup
damn they sent this poor kid away he
already started his work
so now i go in there and i'm there with
all my buddies
like i knew the lpo i was at assaults
with the lpl the chief this is your
platoon that you get put into you're the
aoic the aoic yeah and you just they're
all your boys all my friends from lpo on
up
i didn't know everybody else you know
down
but
and then cool good it was awesome yeah
the oic um so they put me in that
platoon because they were like hey the
oic
you know he's a really good dude he's
just a little um they use the word timid
he's just kind of shy he wasn't a very
outspoken guy and then when i heard him
brief and i heard him on the radio i'm
like no i see whereas like i have no
problem getting on the radio i have no
problem briefing so we actually
complimented each other very well
because he was a good officer like he
knew officer things that i did not right
so he showed me how to be you know like
ground force commander he showed me like
all the checklists all the procedures
and
and um
yeah it was it was a good experience and
i got a lot of reps
you know being the oic because
i was i was good on the radio so i got a
lot of reps and our chief was a complete
stud who i went to buds with
um so i learned a ton from him too he's
a jtac so he taught me a lot about being
a ground force commander where did you
guys go on deployment
we ended up going to uh altacatum
yeah
so we were there for the double a
just advise and assist
so there was no um a company at that
time
so we were just behind the floor just
calling in helping them the iraqis call
in air to try to retake uh al-anbar
which had been retaken by by isil
or you know whatever the name of the
week was for them yeah
and that's uh
how's the platoon what is the platoon
doing as you're doing that
i mean so really the only ones that are
working are the j2x
yeah they're really the only ones that
are working
um but i mean at least you're freaking
killing badges
yeah absolutely but we're also eating
mortars a lot because
we can't go forward so we're just
sitting back there eating mortars and at
one point uh the mortars got really
really close to us blew one of our
humvees up um
uh as i was running towards it this home
v gets hit and just
just blows me on my ass
um so
it's definitely a tbi
so they put me on tbi protocol for a
little bit but
um
right around that time i get an email
telling me like hey
from this chief of mine now he's the sca
now he's se at this point he's like hey
lois you know we're going to actually
send you to baghdad
and you're going to replace this jo as
the strike cell commander
and i'm thinking like why
like i don't know anything about jtac
stuff and the jail that was there he'd
actually gone to like a jtac school
really really intelligent guy like super
intelligent way smarter than me and i'm
like what am i going to do over there
i don't know anything about
you know man he's like and so it's funny
because
as i'm getting on the helo to leave he's
getting there and we're crossing paths
and i'm like bro why am i getting sent
there like i don't know what i'm doing
he's like don't worry about it dude
people like you
i'm just like okay
he's like you're gonna be fine
so you know i get to baghdad and and i
i'm getting the turnover from this jo
and i could immediately see
that these gen the general there is just
not a fan of ours and then through
conversation
um we had we had
we had burned some relationships there
um and
backtracking though
when i checked into team three guess who
my ceo is
it's my first oic
right on man and you want to talk about
like a lack of relationship building um
when i show up he was just like hey
you're that guy that got in trouble for
such and such thing
right on and i'm like freaking awesome
no
i'm like that wasn't me that was someone
else who doesn't even look like me like
he's a white dude like looks nothing
like me
so i'm like way to go man we spent two
years together you don't even know who i
am like that's crazy yeah
anyway so back to the story the
the relationship had definitely been
strained i could just tell by the way
this this general was talking as j.o
and just like
he did not like us
and you know like i said this jail was
very brilliant really knew his jtac
stuff and so now i'm left there and i'm
thinking like man we got to repair this
relationship
so that's actually the first thing i
started doing the general was a marine
corps general
and so i was just chatting him up he's
like hey you know where were you
stationed where are you stationed at
he's like oh cam pendleton i'm like oh
that was my first duty station he's like
what are you doing there i was like i
used to be an fmf corpsman
yeah his eyes just light up
and from that point on you know him and
i just start chatting and then i you
know start asking him like hey you know
what is it that you guys are looking for
when you're looking for these for these
strikes to be approved what can we do to
help out what you guys are doing things
like as a matter of fact you know we
need this this and that and i'm like
check let me see what we can do about it
and so what my job was
was i would get all these air strikes
for the next day that my platoon wanted
to carry out strategically strategic
airstrikes and i had to brief them to
to him and another general to one and a
two star general get them approved in a
room full of kernels that were all jags
and super risk adverse like they were
denying a lot of the airstrikes that's
the reason why i said over there like
hey a lot of our stuff get denied go see
if maybe you can change that up
so
so i go in there and and i grab one of
my jtacs
you know this was actually where i had
like what another epiphany where i'm
like you know what as a leader i don't
have to know everything
i'm like i have someone who went to jtac
school so i'm just going to lean on them
because at the time i'm like i don't
know what i'm doing i was really like
insecure about it like i'm gonna go in
there and just not know what to brief so
i told them i'm like hey listen i'm in a
brief strategic picture like why we're
doing these airstrikes anything
technical you can answer them
and i was like check so that's how i
would do my briefs and like i said i
built that relationship with that
general so every time i briefed you know
and they went around the corner taking
taking the vote he would always take my
side and once he was in the two-star was
gonna be in as well no matter what the
jags said
so from that point on from what i could
remember we got all our airstrikes
approved from that point on
it was just a simple relationship
building
what had the j.o the smart jo
was it something he did or was it just
he was not it was something our ceo did
yeah so
had a bad relationship out of the gate
yeah yeah and then he had a bad taste in
his mouth i think team guys on that
particular deployment he made some some
comments here and there that i caught on
very quickly like check
god
freaking horrible uh and you're did are
you married again at this point
yeah so um
so yeah so when i was in trade i
actually met my wife she was uh my
waitress
a very uh classy establishment
jack called hooters
but uh i went in there with a team guy
and i remember seeing her and i'm
thinking like
oh my god she's gorgeous like there's
absolutely no way someone like that
would you know go for someone like me
and
it turns out that i had gone on a couple
dates with one of her friends
so she had told so she told her friends
she's like oh you know i saw that that
guy he sat at my table that you were
dating she's like oh we're not dating
anymore
she was like do you care if i get his
number and she's like no absolutely yeah
so that's how he ended up uh a meeting
and
so at this point you know we've been
together for a while
since trade and now i was already you
know
at my oic and she was just like hey you
need to marry me if you don't marry me
before this deployment i'm not going to
be here when you get back
so ultimatum delivered
check and and you know it was a hard
decision for me because
i was like man i love this woman but we
you know we fought a lot
and during that deployment that one to
iraq our relationship was very very
stressed
and you had just gotten married before
you went on the plane yeah yeah yeah and
i'm thinking to myself like you know i'm
gonna fail at this marriage thing again
like what am i what what am i doing
wrong here
and what's crazy is like when i was at
trade you know you talked about the four
laws of combat a lot and we talked about
like find what your red flags are
and in the teams my red flag when i got
overwhelmed was
uh you know when that thought came in my
head like i don't know what to do right
now that was my cue to detach
prioritize and execute
and for the longest time i thought that
these four laws of combat this the
social was only
combat related
and it was the first time in my life
where i realized that
it's for your personal life too
because at that point you know i got
back from deployment we're still
fighting a lot but i'm like man i love
this woman i don't want i don't want to
fail at this marriage thing again
and in my head i thought i don't know
what to do right now
and that's when it clicked for me like
wait a minute i've had this thought like
literally hundreds of times when i'm on
training missions where i'm like oh i'm
a little overwhelmed i don't know what
to do right now detach prioritize
execute and so at that point i'm like i
need to detach prioritize and execute in
my personal life
and it was at that point in my life
where i decided to start taking
ownership of of my mistakes and realize
that you know what i'm an imperfect
human being too and i stopped
concentrating on
everything that i thought was a flaw
on her part and just started
concentrating on
how i could become a better husband
so i'm like hey you know what this is
what i do wrong and this is how i can
fix it i have no control over her
attitude i have no the things that i
don't have control over i stopped
worrying about them and i started
concentrating on the things that i could
control and at first it was a little bit
of a campaign
because you could tell she was like what
are you doing
and then and then it got to the point
where
she started doing the same thing
like we just started taking ownership of
our parts of the marriage and i stopped
worrying about what she did wrong and
only worried about what i was doing
wrong and
eventually she started to do the same
and and her marriage is
completely turned around since then and
you know all marriage you got peaks and
valleys but it's it's been
just amazing
when you're in a platoon like where
everybody's taking ownership of stuff no
one's blaming anybody else we're just
trying to solve problems and that's how
that environment finally was in my
marriage
so yeah it's
it's funny when you talk about like when
you're in a platoon and everyone starts
taking ownership stuff you know problems
get solved
what's crazy is the opposite of that
it's not one level of badness when
people are taking ownership because when
they're not taking ownership they're
blaming each other so it's not just oh
we're going to blame each other and
that's that's not good
that's not good but guess what else is
coming now we're fighting we're yelling
at each other like it causes
exponential problems beyond just it's
not just oh if i take ownership the
problems get solved if i don't take
ownership the problems don't get solved
if it was that simple it'd be like you'd
probably deal with it but if now we
actually are fighting we're undermining
each other we're yelling at each other
we we
turn into freaking idiots
and so
yeah and that can happen in people's
personal lives too you know
it's not just that oh well we've got
this problem in our marriage
and it's not my fault it's your fault if
that's where it stopped
you might be able to muddle your way
through it but that's not where it stops
it stops me saying it's your fault what
do you mean it's my fault
actually here's some nine things that
are your fault but all of a sudden we
have not just one little problem that's
not getting solved you have exponential
problems across the board it's a
freaking disaster
yeah it's a game changer
um
now you came back from that deployment
and you actually did a couple years
where you were doing some
uh some classified stuff um overseas
and
obviously we can't talk about things
that are classified um but maybe some
unclassified lessons learned from what
you were doing
yeah um
i think the biggest thing that i learned
while i was over there is is how to
build relationships
and honestly i got i got really into it
and i started trying to perfect that
craft by reading books so i started
reading books like um how to win friends
and influence people
the like switch like anything i could
help get my hands on because i knew that
when i was over there it was just going
to be me and one other operator
that's it we didn't have like a support
system we didn't have a platoon that was
that was us
so we had to build a good relationship
with like the local populace in a very
short amount of time um we had to build
a good relationship with our interpreter
and that's really honestly when it boils
down to it our lives depended on these
relationships because at times
you're asking some of these people to
risk their lives for you
and so that's why i really started
delving into how do i get people to
trust and like me to the point where i
can influence them in the shortest
amount of time
that's really the biggest lesson i got
out of those two years from doing that
that mission set yeah
well that's and that's something that
applies across the board you know it's
funny when you're talking about the
switch going off in your head
of like oh
i can use this that's the same thing
that happened that's what started all
this stuff i went and talked to these
freaking executives about leadership
they started asking me questions and i
was just applying the principles
the four laws of combat take ownership
like that's what i started and it was 36
it was the first question i got asked i
was like oh
oh you have this problem okay here's how
you solve it just based on the
principles that we already know
it's like a freaking
such a nice moment in my life where i
was like oh because i didn't again i
didn't i was totally
institutionalized i didn't understand i
didn't know anything about civilian
companies i didn't know anything at all
about them and all of a sudden i
realized in an instant that oh all this
stuff applies
to all these leadership situations man
and that's the same thing going back to
building relationships it's like oh yeah
guess what
have you ever had a moment in your life
where having an antagonistic
relationship with someone you got to
work with helps it's like that that has
never happened to anybody ever it's
never happened where oh i don't get
along with this person and i have to
work with and it's beneficial to me it
doesn't happen so why are you not
focused on
getting to build relationships with
people it's freaking crazy but good
lessons um
you come back from that and you go back
to trade it again right yep i go back to
trade it as the xo this time
damn exo trade it yeah what are you are
you a lieutenant now i'm a j.o still or
jg
yeah yeah yeah yeah because i did my so
i because i didn't have to go through
buds and everything else i did my first
deployment as an ensign yeah and so you
know i'm a jg now
and um
because i'm prior enlisted and i knew
the ceo there at the time who's also a
prior enlisted guy because actually him
and i had done a deployment we'd done
that iraq deployment together okay at
team one and he was like yeah come on
over i was like you know i
i need to do a disassociated tour
because they were like you need to do
because i was like hey can i go back and
do my platoon commander yeah and they're
like no they're like you need to get
away from it for a little bit because
you know they have like a limit on how
much time you could be deployed
and they're like dude you're like right
there you need to you need to go
somewhere and take a knee so i'm like
trade it sounds good i really like i
really enjoyed my time there and so i
decided to go back
and then you're doing the xo billet
which is not quite as fun as doing that
it's not definitely not as flooded as
being it's not what i thought it was
gonna be so the ceo actually gets the
funner job for sure because he's
actually going to the training trips and
debriefing as the exo you're dealing
with
everything else the admin stuff the
disciplinary problems
getting all the the meetings at group
yeah yeah you were
i'm man my my career was such a freaking
i was just so lucky and everything like
when i went there i was just just the
oic you know so just getting just going
out and training trips and
freaking awesomeness um
at what point so how many years do you
have it at this point this is like 2018
so you're coming up on 20.
yeah is this when you start thinking
about maybe doing something else
yeah so i mean um i figured i had the
time so i'm like hey i'm gonna go knock
out my mba i always really enjoyed
business
and then through conversations they were
like hey after this
they're like you can't do your your um
oh i see until like
2024 or something like that i'm like
what am i gonna do
until then like you do more
disassociated tours
and i'm like you know what that doesn't
sound interesting to me so i think i'm
just gonna retire i mean at that point i
was going to hit 20.
um so i'm like you know what i'm going
to go get my mba and um
and punch out retire so that's at that
point where i started looking into mba
programs and and trying to see where i
was going to go then you end up going
back to usd
no is that right no i went to ucla oh
you went to ucla yeah
yeah it was funny about that is i was
really set on like getting an m7 school
you know like the magnificent seven so
i'm like i'm only gonna go to like
wharton or booth or mit or one of those
and so those are the only ones i applied
to and i realized that the gi bill
doesn't cover
those because
they're private schools
even though like some of them actually
had lower tuition than ucla and at that
point
i had a really good friend of mine one
of my best friends if you look at his
resume it looks almost exactly like mine
like fmf corpsman
uh you know teams usd finance degree and
then he's like hey bro i'm actually
going to go to ucla
and i'm like why is that
and then he's like dude your gi bill
pays for it because it's a public school
and i struggled with that for a little
bill doesn't cover private schools it
only covers like a small portion i was
still gonna have to take out like a
six-figure
a six-figure student loan and i've
always been pretty frugal about my money
i'm like dang i don't want to take out
this huge loan
and then i kind of went into thought i'm
like why do i want to go to one of these
schools like why do i really want to go
and at some point i realized i just want
people to think i'm smart
i mean really we're really like you know
boiling it down on this most simple form
i just want people to think i'm smart
and i'm like you know what i think i
have enough
to get to where i want to go if i go to
ucla
so
i would drive up to la every weekend to
go to school there and knock out my mba
and then from there you
you went into investment banking right
yeah yeah i so i knew that i i you know
like wait what do you do after an mba
like oh everybody does investment
banking or um
or consulting
and i always really liked finance and
then my my buddy i was talking about
kyle roy
when i tell you we got exact same resume
she's like dude i'm going to go be an
investment banker i'm like cool i'm
going to go be an investment banker too
so is he like a year ahead of you or
something we're in the same class but he
actually knew how to do it so he
actually got in so there's a cycle to it
and i didn't know that so when you first
get to your mba program literally the
second you step on campus you're already
recruiting for it you're already
recruiting for the the internship for
that summer
and then you go to your second year and
after you graduate second you start full
time however by the time i figured it
all out i was already on my second year
so i was a year behind
and so nobody really wanted to deal with
me because it wasn't the traditional
path so i just started reaching out to
people on linkedin like
sending them my resume and i would put
in like whatever bank
us uh like i would put uh air force
veteran marine corps veteran i'm like
dude if anybody's gonna answer me it's
gonna be a veteran
and that's how i started getting in was
like a veteran from these banks they
would start reaching out you know they
saw my resume and like
i think they were intrigued
obviously the navy seal part kind of
stands out i'm not gonna lie that's
definitely what got my foot in the door
because some of these other people it's
an extremely competitive job and some of
these people
a way smarter than me and b had like a
legitimate pedigree in the finance world
and so
meanwhile you were ex-overstraight
yeah
so i told my wife you're a good point
man
yeah i told my wife i'm like dude when i
go to these meet and greets because it's
like a million meet and greets because
it's extremely competitive i'm telling
you it's so competitive
um and especially in la because in la
there's a lot less slot like if you go
to new york there's a ton of slots in
new york but everybody wants to be a
warm weather so everybody's like trying
to apply to go to la
and i told my wife i'm like when i go to
these meet and greets like all these
people they're just ridiculously smart i
was like it's pretty intimidating and
then we had this one interview process
where they actually take you in with
your other competitors
so it's like you and two other people
that you're competing with and then you
go and you interview with these bankers
and these these interviews were like
three hours long like you would do half
an hour with this banker and then half
an hour with this banker
and that's when i realized that i belong
there that i could that i had a shot
because the very first that that
interview process wasn't technical at
all it was all about leadership
so when they start coming up with these
questions like tell me about a time
where this happened i'm like cool i have
a story for that i have a story for
everything
and um
it was cool because i would tell my
story and then the guy next to me would
tell his story and it literally got to
the point where i'm not kidding you in
in the interview
the guy next to me was like i really
hate going after him
what am i supposed to say after that
so that's when i'm like oh i got a shot
and you ended up getting hired yeah i
ended up getting the internship so the
internship's like
you know nine weeks long it's basically
like a nine week interview
it was legit like you're you're working
your ass off grind yeah it's a grind
and then you had another year of school
to complete no because i had actually
started my second year i got it so i so
you got so your internship went right
into the job yeah and that was actually
one of the the the things where i used
did you finish school when you're in did
you finish school when you were
still in yeah uh-huh
and then when did you do that nine-week
internship did you leave
damn yeah i was already on my way out
yeah it was like um so like getting
close to terminal lever or whatever
exactly i you i said saved all my leaves
specifically for for for you know me
getting out got it and so i used it all
up then and i got hired and they let me
start right away because
you know i didn't have another year of
school
so
and then i retired and then how did you
like how do you like the uh investment
banking world
uh
i liked i liked a lot of it and i didn't
like other parts of it um
i really liked the mergers and
acquisitions so that's what we did we
did mergers acquisitions and then
leverage buyouts and we were dealing
with big because i got hired with a big
bulge bracket bank so we're working on
like some big deals
and it was exciting it was cool it was
interesting
it just wasn't cool for 18 to 20 hours a
day
like i worked long days it was like an
early night was midnight
but most of the times i'm you know i'm
building powerpoints and xl models till
3 4 in the morning those times where i
didn't sleep at all like our
presentation was due at like 5 a.m and i
turned it in at 5 00 a.m
where were you working out of so home
because it was crazy
yeah so i didn't have to move up to la
which is good because my wife didn't
want to move up there
um but we were set on moving up there
and but it was
every time we drove up there to look at
places the drive home would be very
quiet because we could just tell that
neither of us wanted to move up there
but it worked out for me because like i
said it was covid so they're like hey
we're going to be virtual you know for
the time being
and um
and i think when i realized like i don't
want to do this long term is when i saw
the managing directors i've been there
for a while like i would finish a
presentation you know and it's like four
in the morning like hey you need to call
them
i'm like it's four in the morning like
you need to call managing director to me
he has to look over that powerpoint
before we turn it in and i'm like dang
so i guess this never stops
and you know it was a and i had had a
couple tbis throughout my career
so
my migraine because i wasn't there was
literally nice where i won't go to sleep
at all i'd roll right into the next day
and then my migraines were starting to
get more uh frequent and staring at a
screen like all day long and i'm like
this isn't gonna be a long-term play for
me but i'm gonna tough it out
um
you know for the two or three years or
whatever you gotta be to make vp and
then move on something else and i didn't
realize that the job offers were gonna
start rolling in so quickly
so like once the job offers like
recruiters started reaching out to me
i'm like i'm gonna start looking
elsewhere
and around that time as you know jp had
been talking to me about echelon front
now for for about a year like even when
i was in trade he's like hey you thought
about coming over here and i was i was
interested but i i just never
materialized
you know
and i just went down my path and i told
him hey jp this is actually what i'm i'm
doing now and i'm kind of all in on it
and
so it's around that time i'm i'm already
looking at moving to different firms
i've already got a couple that i'm
pretty close to to signing with and and
then jp calls me one day and he's like
hey bro uh we have a client who you know
about 50 of his employees speak spanish
and i i told him we could deliver
i was like you did
he's like well yeah i got you
because he knew i was fluent in spanish
right
and i was like bro you ever seen office
space
i was like that's my life i have seven
bosses bob
you know so you're i'm on seven
different deals and for each deal i have
to get approved and granted some of them
are you know
have some spillover so there's i'm
working with you know managing director
for two or three different deals so
i'm like dude it's gonna be so hard for
me to get a day off like it's gonna be
near impossible
and he's like bro i really need this and
i'm like all right you know
you know jp is one of my brothers like i
love jp to death so i'm like let me see
what i can do
so i put in the time for two personal
days
and by the way a personal day if it's
funny when you get the email that says
this is what a personal date looks like
you will check your email you know like
six times during that day and if you
need something you will answer it so
it's really like a personal day you're
so freaking working
so i'm like i took two personal days to
come out and help them out with this ftx
and um
so i would literally you know teach all
day long and then i pulled an
all-nighter trying to catch up on all
the work that i missed throughout the
day so i didn't sleep for like those
three days that i was there
um
but it was cool because i i showed up
and it was this construction company and
when i showed up
i could tell that that some of the guys
weren't happy to be there and not
because they're you know lazy or
anything they just wanted to go to work
they're hard-working people you know so
they're like they want to be working
instead of being in this leadership
course
and so let's see i think i think it was
a thursday
yeah it was a thursday where the first
day of class started and we split the
the class and two because they had so
many people that we were going to teach
one class one day and then the other
group that's next day and on saturday we
did like a debrief tying it all back
into their business
so day one i'm teaching i could see it
that you know they'd rather be working
than be there
one of their foreman who you know it's
like one of their rock star foreman
shows up late
like same thing he's like man i'd rather
be working right now he won't be there
and then at the end of the day i i
noticed the switch
like they i could tell that they were
enjoying themselves and they were
learning stuff and it was clicking the
light bulbs were coming on
and at the end of the day this foreman
he comes up to me he's like hey man i'm
really sorry that i showed up late can i
come back tomorrow and do it all over
again i was like it's fine with us as
long as your your boss is cool with it
and he's like okay
so he comes back the next day
you know and does the full day of
training with echelon front
and
on the third day
when i
heard their debrief points and the
impact that it made i mean some of these
debris point there it was like emotional
like it was like legit and i was like
wow like you guys are doing something
really great here
um
and i felt good about it
you know their ceo was just
just cared so much he's super super
intelligent guy very caring very humble
and it was just a pleasure talking to
him and seeing how much he cared about
his team and his people and then seeing
how these other people appreciated now
really started to appreciate the fact
that he did this for them like was
trying to develop them as leaders
because he cared about them he cared
about the company
and i told jp i'm like man that felt
good
i haven't felt good about what i was
doing for work for for a while since i
left the teams
and
that's when i was like okay
let's have a serious conversation of
what this could possibly look like for
me joining ef so
so here you are you know that that
little um
the little
obstacle that you get over with and then
obviously i've been doing this for a
long time now but there's a little
obstacle with some people when they show
up for training and the obstacle is
well there's there can be several of
them but one of the biggest obstacles is
they don't yet understand that
leadership is a skill
and that it's something that they use
and it's something that they can
actually learn and get good at and it
doesn't take very long in those sessions
where people go oh wait that's me oh
wait i could use that
and all of a sudden they realize
this is gonna make my life so much
better and it's gonna make my team's
life so much better and that that is so
gratifying to see that and what's really
awesome
is
when you look up in three months six
months or a year and now you see where
that company is and they their
trajectory that that changes for a
company and how they elevate and move
forward man it's freaking it's very very
rewarding to say the least
yeah every time i do another job i'm
just
just solidifies that decision for sure
it's weird uh were you thinking
because because the first gigs that you
did was teaching ftx which is like our
field training exercise which is
[Music]
you know i'm jp and i've talked about
this where i'm like hey jp people don't
they don't need to really like know how
to clear a room yeah it's just it's
funny almost the human instincts that
you have of how you would clear a room
are good enough
to do the ftx's it's not about teaching
people how to you know the tactics of
combat it's just it's about teaching
them leadership but it's funny
like even the plans they come up with
like we give them a target
their plans are like perfectly fine
they're perfectly fine yeah no sometimes
they're not that great sometimes they
make mistakes but a lot of times it's
like yeah you know what that's that
would work that would work on this
target for real and these are people
that are civilians cause
let's face it hitting a target of bad
guys there's it's not rocket science
it's not rocket science to figure out
what you're going to do and we give them
enough basics that they can figure it
out but
for me you know the the leadership
laboratory that we got to work in when
we were actually in and actually a trade
at and actually seeing platoons go
through that is such a powerful thing
because
man when you are in those situations
you feel it and when you like you think
oh i'm good at detaching and then you go
on a run where you're freaking yelling
and screaming and you you know and you
say oh how was that detachment on the
last run as you were yelling and
screaming at everybody and shooting your
weapon a bunch and not and no one took
charge of anything so obvious
when you actually experience it and you
learn that lesson so much more
thoroughly when you actually experience
it's freaking awesome to watch yeah
absolutely i've had messages like on on
instagram or linkedin
where people have gone through our
training it's like hey i had this
situation at work and i thought about
that time when you took the gun away
from me and told me to lead you know
because when they're not detached and
they're just getting after it with their
gun but they're actually in charge
like every now and then i'll take their
gun away and i'm like hey lead now you
can lead because you don't have a gun
and and so you know the right back like
i remember the time you did this to me
or you said this to me and and i say
that at ftx's i'm like hey you know
going through that pain
actually solidifies that lesson way more
it's like bruce lee says the pain will
leave you when it's done teaching you
it's one of my favorite quotes
um and i tell people that too like in my
brief in the morning i'm like hey we're
not here to teach you leadership i mean
we're not here to teach you tactics
we're here to teach you leadership and
in the absence of knowledge because you
don't have any you know knowledge doing
this what do you have to lean back on
your leadership which is simply you
trying to influence another 25 people
towards a common goal
so you're going to have to use all those
tools that we've you know talked about
and the groups that do the best are the
ones that are able to apply it
immediately like they make that
connection
and the ones that struggle are the ones
that you know
can't seem to do that you know what's
interesting i was just thinking about
this um from a jiu jitsu perspective how
long have you been training jiu jitsu
for
since 2012
so what's interesting is you know people
like you take a normal dude yeah
and you say hey what did that doesn't
train
and you think hey if you get in a fight
what would you do they kind of like they
kind of think what is it that the hey
i just see red bro
you know i'll go off bro like that's
kind of what they think they think that
that is how they're gonna fight and
that's how they would win in a fight
like hey i'll just freaking make it
happen
and that's totally ignorant that's one
of the most ignorant things you could
say and if you go against someone that's
trained then you're absolutely going to
lose but there's also a really good
chance you'll lose anyways
imagine this
there's people that that are in
leadership positions that their
mentality is that exact same thing hey
oh if i'm in charge i'll tell people
i'll handle it and and they could
literally learn
jujitsu for leadership we have jiu jitsu
for leadership it's like an amazing
untapped knowledge that like the gracies
the gracies brought jiu-jitsu to the
world and all of a sudden people like oh
i can choke people i don't i can defeat
someone that's bigger than me i can
avoid getting hit like there's all these
amazing things that we literally did not
know as humans we did not know and if
you would have gotten a fight in if i
would have gotten no fight in
1990 or 1991
i would
do what my instincts are throw hay
makers whatever like whatever it is a
human
is gonna do is what i would do and then
all of a sudden as soon as i learned oh
the joke
like all of a sudden you know what to do
and now you can handle all these
situations
and it's the same thing with what we
teach it's like oh this isn't some
this isn't some mysterious thing like
here's oh this is an arm lock
it's called cover and move here's uh
taking the back this is keeping things
simple you can actually learn maneuvers
for leadership and that's what hits
people when they're going through our
programs you can see it in their face
they're like oh
oh i remember when a guy was doing this
to me and all i had to do back was was
diminish you know dimit reflect and
diminish i could have taken that angry
person
and
reflected some of those emotions but
diminished them and then
i could reflect in such a way that they
would realize that i'm on their side and
then we'd be able to have a real
conversation and move this thing forward
that's one move
there's all these moves you can learn
and man it's just like this you know
what it's actually the same look when
somebody does jiu jitsu in whatever
moment because different people get it
at a different time that moment where
they go oh
this is amazing like oh it all makes
sense i think it's sometimes when people
realize that
you know oh and then you sweep them and
you're in the mount and they go oh it
all is connected you see that look in
their eyes and i see that looking like
that's what you're talking about like
the guy that you're talking about that
came back at the end of the day like hey
can i come tomorrow because he realized
that it's all connected that leadership
is a skill that he could actually
utilize these tools to go out there and
lead his team with with skills and with
techniques and with procedures
moves
man it's
freaking empowering
legit
um
and that's where you're at right now
yeah we just went through your whole
damn life bro
yep that that's pretty impressive
we'll have to uh i know there's i know
you had some uh some stuff that you
wrote down for me that we didn't cover
today that we'll probably cover on cover
on the next time as did you know get a
little bit more granular on some of
these things that you experienced for
sure um but probably a pretty good place
to wrap it up
of course echo probably has some
questions at this point well i'll keep
getting
questions i'll keep it simple oh have
you ever heard that you look like oscar
de la hoya
every day of my life since i was 16. i
understand completely as a matter of
fact in my platoons they already knew it
was coming and so when we would go out
like you know people would be like hey
is that and they were like yo there it
is yep where is security yeah that's
what they would say
and uh
just just not not too long ago i was in
new york and i was with my wife and this
guy comes up to me he's like hey man i
still think pound for pound you're the
best
and then she's like are you gonna
correct him and i'm like i'm tired of
correcting people but then it's like
more people started coming like hey guys
i'm not oscar
the buff version of oscar de la hoya the
jacked version
the jack version i've gotten that
forever
yeah that is an uncanny resemblance
i uh yeah who do you look like echo
charles jade
too easy though you've been asked that
one before that was too easy
got that twin brother uh yeah man like i
said we'll dig into some more of the
stuff in the future probably a good
place to wrap it today um
sounds good
echo charles yes sir
sounds like
it kind of seems like carlos has gotten
a lot done
yes he has i'm thinking maybe we should
all uh do more what do you think we
should do where do we start
well you mentioned jiu jitsu
what a good place to start yes sir
um yeah we wanted to do a purple belt
yeah purple belt 2012 it's 21 it's nine
year when did you eat a purple bell just
recently yeah but off and on that's yeah
i was on deployment a lot and
and then i would i bounced around a
couple schools and um
i'm training actually with your buddy
aaron hernandez oh right on dude he's
awesome freaking awesome
yeah he's he's awesome you you know like
i started he started training that when
we were at fabio santos he was like 10
years old
pictures i want to see those pictures
bro that's freaking rad what yeah
he's awesome man his dad like would just
come i i
his
a lot of times nowadays you see like the
dad's all into jiu-jitsu and that's why
the kids are there yeah almost against
their will
it didn't seem like aaron's dad was into
it but he's like oh this is what my kid
wants to cool i'm gonna sit here every
day you know for two hours on the bench
waiting for my kid to get done with this
whatever this weird stuff is that he's
doing yeah
freaking legit so what's that 2012
so you're almost 10 years deep
yeah yeah got that purple underachieving
purple it happened yeah so yeah even
life was like that too right dude
life was a white belt bro i started
training those guys in 2005 but actually
he had trained before that
leif had trained at fabios
before 2005. yeah so leif was like white
belt for
i mean long time yeah a long time as we
used to say in hawaii around
a long time yes sir long time i was
perfectly happy at blue belt yeah and
aaron was like bro okay
he got it he got to do it
yeah blue belt is the only blue belt is
the last chance you have to be under the
radar yeah because once you're a purple
belt right people expect you there's a
there's yeah you
you can get tapped you can literally get
tapped by a white belt as a blue belt
and it's not that big of a deal right
you're kind of like well you know i'm
just a blue belt just a blue belt it
covers a lot of ground i was a blue belt
for a long time too
i was a blue belt because i was a blue
belt i got my blue belt in san diego but
then i moved to virginia beach and i
mean dude and i was training
when i was in san diego training all the
time and then when i got to virginia
beach i did a couple deployments so i
wasn't training as much but even when i
was on the phone and i would train with
the boys
but i was still a blue belt so it was
years i think i was a blue belt for like
i wanna and then when i got back to san
diego
fabio you know i had to like re-earn my
risk it was like i it was like when i
wasn't at fabio's he's i wasn't training
he was like whatever i don't know where
you were you might have gotten better
but it doesn't count we're starting
where you left off yeah we started where
i left off with him
so it took me another
another probably i think i was a blue
belt for like five years yeah blue belt
and i
i never buy my wife anything like hardly
ever a poor woman
but when i got my purple belt when i got
my purple belt i got up i went to a
flower store it got a purple flower
of some kind or like five purple flowers
and brought them up that's i was so
stoked that i wanted my wife to be kind
of stoked too to get that purple belt
but and and i was ready for it too like
i mean
when i got my purple viles ready for
that purple bow i had somebody so i got
their black belt the other day a friend
of mine got a black belt the other day
he's like i'm not ready for it i was
like no one feels like they're ready for
their black belt no almost no one right
maybe you just won worlds or whatever
yeah
but you're not just like oh yeah i
forget who it was i think it might have
been clark
gracie i think i could be wrong so
whatever um but it was the kind where he
he was weaning everything as a brown
belt everything and and i think he was
like i don't know if it was the coach or
whatever someone was kind of like oh
wait
is he doing that just so he can win a
bunch
and someone was like bro like he he
can't compete as a brown belt anymore
it's like someone has to give him his
black belt like that's that's the only
exception i could ever think of yeah
well dean list won adcc is a brown belt
yeah oh yeah
yeah but via submission by the way
absolute by the way
so uh so we're thinking jiu jitsu is
good yes jiu-jitsu is good fitness is
good carlos is in great shape you know
mm-hmm and always good to see you so we
got some healthy uh how should i say
healthy we want to go in a healthy
direction mentally physically i'm saying
so i'm gonna talk about energy drinks
first
because that's you know
kind of what we do from time to time so
we got jocko discipline go energy drink
healthy energy drink by the way if you
didn't know carlos i did those things
power the ftx's i know
it was like a softball what do you call
rhetorical kind of question right
because i know i know you know but the
the the discipline go scenarios
um so yes so yeah we will drink energy
drinks now as long as it's this kind
yeah yeah for sure because the other
kind
bad it's bad literally it's it's a
dichotomy well this kind completely bad
for you legitimately bad for you and
this isn't like oh well jocko's trying
to sell his energy drink no i'm telling
you those other energies are
factually bad for you we have one that
is factually good for you yes sir
factually you know that there's a uh i
don't know the service but you can do it
online i was gonna do it for a video
it's gonna make a long time ago before
all this where you can make your own
energy drink like if you want oh you
know carlos extra thunder energy drink
or whatever and you can kind of pick a
flavor and then like
they'll design the thing or you can
design the thing and then you just get
it but it's all like the similar like if
you want cherry blast or whatever i
don't know what you'd call it but if you
get like a cherry flavored one it's like
the same cherry flavored as like you
know jocko cherry blast what i'm saying
i would do lemon lime lows
you know what's interesting is you might
you might think yourself this is good
because you did the investment banking
thing for a while
and did you guys take any companies
public
so actually during my internship i
worked on an ipo it's interesting
because we work with a bunch of public
companies obviously
but you might think to yourself like hey
well why doesn't everyone just make you
know an energy drink that's good for you
do you think that right like hey well
that just seems like that seems like a
good idea yeah
and here's the deal
it's more expensive
it's more expensive and it's going to
cut into your profit and as soon as you
get into a point in a company where
you're like oh
we we want to do the right thing and
make the best product
and we are not going to make as much
money there's like
armies of people that tear you apart and
say no just freaking make more money
it's the same it's the same thing with
you know with our hard goods with our
clothing
the as soon as you get to a point where
you can make jeans oh we're making jeans
as soon as someone goes hey we could
shave
48 cents off the price per pair of those
jeans
there's an army of people that say do it
they sell they say sell your soul that's
what they say and it works of course i
mean it works think about it too
especially the more you sell right where
okay i'm gonna do this oh we're gonna
shave 48 cents when you're selling like
10 pair or 10 whatever it's like 40
cents it's like what four dollars
i'd rather keep my integrity yeah but
once the numbers start going way up
there and 48 cents means like another
like i don't know half a million dollars
for you or whatever you're like oh i
think that 48 cents yeah you know so
it's a literal selling of the soul
literal selling of the soul man because
like this is pasteurized right which
means we have to put chemicals in it
which by the way this is chemicals that
everybody uses they all throw them in
there hey there's not that bad right
right it's not that bad yeah yeah sell
yourself we'll say industry standard
yeah you know it's the industry
standards you can kind of shrug your
shoulders and be like well you know
that's the way everyone's doing it well
there's certain like toxins right where
like the fda is like well you just keep
them below this level and technically
it's like it's legal or whatever it's
like considered not
harmful or whatever if we pound like
three of those every day you know it's
crazy big trouble big trouble now the
last not with these obviously it's good
so yeah get on some of that that'll help
you that'll help us you know move you in
the right direction yes sir staying fit
and mentally because the the cognitive
stuff in there as well also
keep your joints in uh in the game as
well you know if you still if you want
to work out as you get older mm-hmm you
joined you left that pain
no not did you lift today i did yeah
what time you lift what time do you
usually work out
it's not 4 30
it's i saw today i got up at 6.
okay what'd you do
uh just like don't not do but like
roughly what'd you do do pull ups do you
what did you do today's leg day me too
let me just happen to be this is a
sunday yeah but here's what's cool i got
done i was ju
my my son opened the door to my garage
and i could you know feel his presence
there
and normally he's wanting to jack steal
himself
and i've racked the weight squats
racked away turn around and he goes how
many more you got and i go i'm done
because i was literally done and he goes
waves are good at the pier and i go
let's hit it
is it cold right now
kind of cold it's california it's
california meaning it's not going to
freeze but it's not going to be warm
either are we using a wetsuit right now
i use the wetsuit today there you go
weakness weakness no no no efficiency
look do you want to enjoy surfing you
don't want to enjoy surfing
you know what the weird thing is frankly
if you go surfing without a wetsuit it's
only cold for the first
most days i mean if sure if it's
freezing but most days it's only cold
for three minutes and then it's just
normal and you feel fine those for three
minutes though that's what puts people
that's what has people squeezing in that
damn wetsuit yeah and also when you're
in the cold water they
like you'll handle and maybe for
like an i mean it depends who you are
obviously but after like an hour it's
almost like the coldness like you get
hit with that initial coldness and your
body's like ah it's not that cold
actually so we're cool plus you're
generating heat from all the stuff but
then the coldness kind of on a strategic
level starts to just seep in yeah and it
kind of hits you like i'm kind of this
it's kind of weird here's a big factor
do you surf carlos no i don't here's a
big factor if you're gonna be catching a
lot of waves and there's good waves
coming in you're gonna be fine
but if it's one of those days we're
gonna be waiting and there's a little
brisk breeze at your back yeah you're
gonna get chilly whoo oh yeah
two factors with that because one you're
not having
fun you know like oh you endure like you
actually don't even notice a lot of
stuff when you're having like fun you
don't notice how tired you're getting
you don't know notice a lot of stuff
cole's probably one of those when you're
you know hitting and then uh you're
moving way less yeah and then you're
just sitting there just being cold just
sitting there being cold man now there's
a let's face it that's kind of legit
you know when i when i see someone
scanning it
like props you get ins i'm giving you
props if you're skinny you're getting
problems maybe if it's the dead of
summer
but any other time
if it's not
if it's not august
and you're skinning it i give you a
little bit of a little bit of and
sometimes myself too yeah i'll be like
you know what we're gonna do it yeah
yeah yeah a little skinned
because when you go through buds
did you have wetsuits that had like legs
connected to them when you went through
buds
no i don't think so we just had shorties
oh no i had like beaver tail oh so
that's what we had at first recon
battalion okay for tails so when i got
the buds i'm like dang they give these
students better wetsuits
what's beaver tail
it's like uh you're the back of the
wetsuit has like a long tail on it and
it comes up underneath your crotch and
like snaps into position in front of you
it does nothing to hold in any water at
all it's the dumbest invention ever
whoever invented the beaver tail is an
idiot you would never come up with that
plan right yes
so
because but now they have where the the
shirt of the wetsuit is connected to the
trunks which is a whole different ball
game this is a whole different ball game
this is a totally different situation
and they get that in buds by the way you
got that in buds
i don't think i've ever worn a wetsuit
ever
i can't remember one single time
interesting that's the way it doesn't
know why it rises above every down here
shredding
anyway back to our joints
we don't we don't want to have joint
problems that's another thing cold water
is good for you yeah that is by the way
that's where you got to get in that bath
yeah in the ice bath but if you're not
going to jump in the ice bath as often
as maybe you could you just keep the
what's called joint warfare super krill
oil supplement just take the supplement
so you know easy way so you don't got to
freeze yourself vitamin d
take vitamin d 100
take that every day yeah like
cold war
keep the immunity strong uh you can get
all this stuff from jackalful.com
get some mulk too yeah cause let's face
it man
let's face it that's a tough one it's a
tough one to not bro did you see that
did you i posted some steaks i had the
other day yes i saw that
it was amazing
yeah people
people sent me steaks
which is like the only like yeah people
send mistakes those were from
they were you know jack arnold
jack yeah uh he's he's a barbecue yeah
yeah
he sent those
is that the ones that he he always cooks
i think it's
maybe i don't know they're cow k-o-w but
damn they were good they were good yeah
they looked so good
even when i got done eating those even
when i got done eating a freaking
full-on tomahawk steak
i was like cool
guess what i wanted a little bit of
sweetness a little bit of goodness a
little bit what's that other word
uh it's like
savory savory is like steak right yeah
like salty or whatever right and then
sweet
what's milk it's got both
well if you think about it the real good
desserts the flavors have like a little
bit of like savor like a little bit of a
little bit
yeah and then if you think about it like
the good like savory has a little bit of
sweet too and you think about it so
we're talking about milk basically
it's hot season by the way it's
like there's having a hot mulk
in the morning oh man
i'm not talking early morning like
pre-workout i'm talking nine o'clock in
the morning
starting to feel a little bit of hunger
it's a little bit cool outside hot milk
coming at you live yeah that's uh do i
throw whipped cream on top of that i do
that's still paleo well yeah actually a
lot of whipped cream well i don't know
but a lot but the one that my wife buys
it's actually not that bad for you yeah
it's actually pretty solid i'm surprised
by that keeping it real with that keto
very happy with it
jack did you sell some mold too that's
clean protein though by the way we don't
really mention that because like
sometimes remember back in the day or
whenever you didn't take milk you take
protein shake you got the
let's face it like you get some
secondary effects yeah you know from
that not the kind this effects you want
negative yes sir yes sir but no it's not
like that anymore but yeah there's that
and then also jacqueline tea the old
school if you like tea hot tea now
obviously yep and if you like dead
lifting by the way yes sir you're gonna
want that jogger to go on but yeah
yeah get it all at jocklefield.com also
uh the energy drinks you already said
right vitamin chocolate
by the way i don't know if i'm supposed
to talk about this or not yet but we got
we got some ready to drink mulk coming
oh yeah yeah and um that's nice
let's just say
i
i'm not saying that the creators the the
the creators deserve a nobel prize i'm
not saying that it's definite but they
should be in the contention they should
be mentioned there should be a mention
okay when you try these things
yeah yeah so you're gonna be able to in
the future go into a wawa boom go
restraint and just get mulk on tap bro
like
and actually that makes sense when you
think about it because it's not like
when you think about what if you spend
any time thinking about it
maybe i do maybe i don't i don't know
but either way it's like you can't just
because milk is the powder right and
then you have your mix like you know
we'll put in the banana we'll put in the
whatever right and it's like there's
variations of mixes and variations of
results and it makes sense so it's like
hey if you're going to drink the ready
to drink one you got to commit to a very
specific mix across the board per flavor
you see i'm saying so now you got to
rely on whoever expert
i know they're an expert i'll tell you
that you ever had something come into
your life that you just you just came
out of nowhere
like you couldn't have predicted it uh
yeah let me tell you something
salted caramel i didn't even know what
this
this was not in my world never in my
world this idea salted caramel what is
this like what is this
so we have a salted caramel version
i'm actually familiar with the salted
caramel so that one to me that makes
sense that sounds delicious all right so
there we go
also get it also origin usa this is
american-made stuff not just any stuff
it's like for real american-made like
products jeans boots some wallets on
there the accessories i've been going
kind of deep on the accessories
recently on that website
pretty impressive just getting in there
oh yeah so yes everything from the
material all the way to the product all
made in america
quality stuff too if you care about the
people and the process
if you care about humanity yes sir how's
that yes sir if you care about humanity
go to originusa.com
because
you know what you were talking about
earlier carlos um you know seeing people
these people are hard workers and the
first time you worked with an echelon
front client you're like man these
people are working hard they want to do
a good job
and that's awesome that's that's so
awesome that we get to experience all
these people across the country but then
there's industries and there's
corporations that say you know what
to hell with those people
to hell with those hard-working people
we're gonna offshore this stuff we're
gonna put it in the slave labor camps
we're gonna give money to communists
that's what we're doing
that's what we're doing that's
that's what we're doing we're gonna
we're gonna have slave people
build this stuff and we're gonna give
money to communist regimes that's what
we'll do how's that sound and that kind
of goes along with that 48 cents like
don't let that don't let that happen go
to orange and usa get to your boots get
your jeans
your ghee get your key for sure you have
jingya you don't
rudolph well actually in a way that's
100 my fault yeah yeah it's 100 my fault
i feel like it's 100 your fault too but
i actually feel bad too because
like what we were just what i was just
talking about something coming into your
life when you put on an origin for real
when you put on an origin geek it is for
real you got some other thing coming in
your life that you did not expect was
that thing yeah there's that i i will
take you as soon as we get done
recording i'll take you you can you can
touch one of mine they're too big for
you
what is this what sort of uh uh unicorn
fur is this that's been used to create
this thing because it's a different
level man yeah it's a different level
yeah that's what's gonna say
i was gonna say that's kind of good news
in a way for me so like you know i can
kind of like you know someone's about to
do something really like whether it be
fun or cool or it's gonna be real
beneficial and then you get to like
experience it with them you know it's
like you get to
share that experience you get to see
that's what's kind of good news can't
wait for you yeah you know you've got
origin rash guards those are awesome
yeah i do use those yeah made in america
yeah just imagine that made in america
it's true
beautiful thing go also chocolate store
it's called jacqueline store that's
where you can get your discipline equals
freedom shirts the jiu-jitsu shirt and i
noticed that you are representing
hardcore by the way
oh yeah so there's it there's a kind of
a jiu-jitsu section
yes
how many shirts are in the jiu-jitsu
section right now just that one
limited section but nonetheless does it
have its own breakout area yeah when
dean's shirt comes out it will and this
is going to say foot right just like
yours is good says foot actually that's
his technically that's his design right
i just saw this sticker someone put a
sticker on the gym out here and it's got
it's got like an old nom
picture of a dude with like a a steel
pot helmet on
in nom american but it's dean lister's
face and it says foot soldier
see we might have to have a d mister sex
and that whole thing that's true so
there you go but yeah
good spot to get this stuff chocolate
store where uh the like i said just
finished freedom jiu-jitsu stuff uh good
that's a good one you watch the army
navy game yeah let's face it
good goes deep we'll say that
we we did uh we did appreciate that and
it kind of worked for navy or was this
yes apparently in the assessment fully
yes sir seemed like it worked out good
speak for themselves but yeah um also we
have the shirt locker which is the new
shirt every month um they're separate
from the regular store but it's a new
shirt they're a little bit more creative
would say some good good feedback on
that one
got things squared away too by the way
we got one coming out too right there
should be a new one coming out pretty
soon yeah so if i'm not sure what so
right now like now if you join you'll
get that shirt for that month you know
before it was like okay i joined in the
next month your shirt kind of comes but
it's all squared and right away all that
kind of stuff it's good squared so yeah
we got december still going and then
yeah january there's another one that's
how it works
you know that's what that's what monthly
shirt means subscribe to that if you
also subscribe to this podcast
we got
this podcast we got taco unraveling we
got the grounded podcast we got the
warrior kid pocket podcast we also have
choco underground jocko underground.com
we're on there answering questions life
advice life advice alternative
topics that apply to
everything
if you know if you if you know the way
broadway broadly you see it on all
things
that it also protects us because listen
we don't know what's going to happen in
the world but we do know that sometimes
people want to control what you say
they want to control what we say
we haven't read any major issues yet a
couple we brushed up against a couple
we'd have a couple scenarios unfold and
just in case just to protect us from
that we gotta have a contingency plan
that's shock underground.com go there if
you wanna support uh costs eight dollars
and eighteen cents a month and we give
you this extra podcast but
look if you can't afford that it's okay
email assistance at
dockowunderground.com we just got to
have somewhere as an alternative
place to be in case
so that's where we're at
youtube channel yep we have a youtube
channel you want to see uh oscar de la
hoya
carlos mendez how are you you know he's
handsome you're more jacked though thank
you so that's what that would be the
telltale sign i think if the if someone
runs into you in the street you're gonna
be like dang that's oscar de la hoya
he's like yeah i've been lifting yeah
yeah this
it's true
but yes if you want to see what you know
what he looks like youtube channel video
version of this podcast and excerpts
yeah which is important yeah also uh
check out origin's
youtube channel yeah it's good to know
what's happening for instance covet
outbreak in maine you know about that i
did not know yeah see so if you you
would you would know about that
uh covet outbreak in maine we had like
40 people
oh yeah i did yeah okay yeah i watched
them but which is a bummer yeah we got
people coming back in now but black
friday do you know what that is yes sir
after thanksgiving people go shopping
yeah i heard yeah yeah and we sold a
bunch of stuff which is awesome and then
everyone got sick with covet or a bunch
of people got sick with kovid so now
we're trying to play catch up
and uh pete making moves trying to make
it happen
amanda that's a big like learning
channel too when you think about it
because you can see like um like of
course how the inner workings of
american business is but like how that
just like this just like and they
they've done it many times before where
it's like an issue will come up and you
can see like how they'll solve the issue
and it's unique to that specific thing
so it's like okay you can kind of it's
like a demonstration yep
um psychological warfare
if you got any
moments of weakness you can overcome
them press play on your phone hit play
got an mp3 out there yep how many tracks
do you remember it's i think it's seven
or nine i forget nine track something
yeah so
nine
nine give or take
moments or types of moments of weakness
you got coverage for that check
also dakota meyer has a company called
flipside canvas flipsidecanvas.com go
there get cool stuff to hang on your
wall
if you don't have a if you don't have a
elk
head to hang on your wall yeah
then you can get one of these things as
an alternate alternate thing to hang on
your wall
books we got some books um
final spin that just came out
getting freaking awesome reviews which
is crazy it's crazy to
think of something weird and then write
it and then people give you cool reviews
right very very cool
it's not what you expect i have to say
that
that's a lot of people said i wasn't
expecting this in fact some people go i
wasn't expecting the story to go this
way
again
we're not very we're less predictable
possibly than you know some people might
think
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual
the code the evaluations protocol this
link was freedom field manual
way the warrior kid one two three and
four this is the book to get for all the
kids that you know
and by the way sometimes people are like
well does is it appropriate for girls
yes
girls boys kids
get these freaking books for the kids
this is the christmas season get there's
no better gift you can get a kid than
these books
that's a that's a bold statement carlos
do you think that's a bold statement
no better no better gift i would have to
agree i grew up with books and loved
books
i don't think they don't read enough
these days i don't think there's a
better gift you can give a kid than the
way the warrior kid books
and i got many many many kids and
parents that will back that up
that aren't me
mike and the dragons you can also get
that for the little kids
warning
little warning when you read that to
your kids
you might start crying it's happened
before echo charles no that was
way the word kid won oh really uncle
jacob oh no okay when i was making the
video yeah a little bit for mikey and
the dragons yeah getting a little teared
up over there well that was you guys
where the word kid when uncle jake's
spoiler alert by the way when uncle jake
had to went home yeah
that was kind of sad dude i was laughing
when when i read that one story and you
were crying like really hard
on the podcast i wasn't crying that's
the thing i was crying so hard he edited
it down people do it at the podcast so
i'm like no we never had it he edited it
down i didn't realize it until later
because he was crying and couldn't put a
sentence together and then
i started laughing so hard and i'm like
bro you can't break down like this
he's talking about he's talking about a
hawaii 5-0 and he's breaking down it was
a sad scene is what i was saying or a
happy scene sorry so warning mikey and
the dragons might catch you off guard if
you're feeling emotionally vulnerable
yeah then it might catch you a little
bit so just you know stay strong stay
strong stay focused don't let yourself
break down
about faced by hackworth
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
that actually helped your marriage that
attitude
taking ownership of this that's true i
went back and read the book again but in
a different way because the first time i
read it i was like okay i want to be a
better leader in combat so that's kind
of like the vision i had when i was
reading it and then the second time i'm
like wait a minute i'm going to read it
from my life my personal life yeah yeah
yeah that's a good stupid lens it's such
a useful switch we're like because
that's a big thing right where it's like
oh yeah these big bad navy skills
they're going to tell me how to run my
daycare center like
no way like in real life no way but it's
like just like yes yes exactly right
where it's like the navy sea like all
the combat stuff that's just the example
essentially it's just an example of
these principles like
being used in these like
situations or whatever but and since
they they are useful in everything
if you look at it in the in the sense of
word this is they're talking to me for
my specific situation and using the the
battlefield as a metaphor for sure but
they're talking to me for me for my
specific situation it's like oh shoot
everything checks out yeah and as you
read things from different perspectives
like yeah you can read it from a
professional perspective like you did
the first time carlos
then you read it from a personal
perspective the next time but then guess
what happens you get promoted
read it again you see it from another
perspective again then you have a
problem where you get moved to a new
team and everything's the dynamics are
different read it again it's a you will
have a different perspective and you
will pick up more things from those
books
also
we have a leadership consultancy we were
just talking about echelon front
salonfront.com if you want to do any of
the things that we talk about on this
podcast if you want to learn the
information go to echelonfront.com it's
what we do we
do
look we do the ftx that's one part of it
we also do leadership training that's
not experiential so you're going to sit
down learn with us but we'll still make
it dynamic through role playing and
other
other methodologies that we have
so
if you want to check some of that out go
to ashlandfront.com you having fun there
carlos oh yeah
it's awesome i mean the people that you
meet are just amazing as well because i
mean people that call for extreme
ownership are not lazy people they're
people who just want to take it to the
next level so i honestly haven't met a
client yet that i just
didn't really like and i and it's
awesome because you keep in touch with
them like they hit you up every now and
then and
they kind of become your friends oh for
sure for sure i get
texts all the time i get texts from that
are like hey we just did this it's
awesome i'll also get texts like hey can
i talk to you and they'll have some
situation going on it's like all right
what do you got what do you got let's
work through this hey we also have an
online
training academy
and
there's a bunch of reasons why we
started that the biggest reason why we
started it is because
like i was saying earlier about
jiu jitsu and actually having a skill
and getting good at this thing called
leadership
well just like jiu jitsu you can't go to
one class and be like okay cool i'm good
now i know it no it takes repetition it
takes understanding the various angles
it takes expanded knowledge it takes
confronting different scenarios multiple
times so you understand how to
understand them
you learn to understand how to
imagine that you're looking at a
situation
you don't know what to do you can
actually understand how to understand
that
so this doesn't happen overnight that's
why we that's the why we made extreme
ownership.com
and the online training academy um we're
on there all the time there's courses
that you can take you can go live
sessions
i'm on there two or three times a week
answering questions face to face like on
the zoom call it's a zoom call
you wanna ask me a question come on
there extreme ownership.com if you wanna
check that out
if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families you want to help gold
star families check out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization does a ton of incredible
stuff for our
veterans if you want to donate or you
want to get involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org
actually i just heard joe rogan talking
about hyperbaric chambers
so
that's one of the big things that mama
lee does is she takes service members
and gets them hyperbaric chamber
treatments for like 30 straight days so
good for you so helpful
so check that out if you want
and if you want more of my just
continued droning talking
or you need more of echoes
just
just unknown randomness
um yeah you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on instagram on facebook i'm
at echo charles eck and
i am at jacqueline echoes at echo
charles
carlos
was was is now on the gram i am carlos
underscore mendez underscore 246.
that's correct that was your entry into
the social media world right yeah i
didn't have one in the teams and uh when
i came onto echelon front jp told me
open one up
and new world out there i could watch so
many jiu jitsu videos
yeah it's funny how they know what you
like it's like how am i already getting
this yeah the whole algorithm thing
like the algorithm thing
i wrote the other day fight the
algorithm but the problem is when the
jiu jitsu video start rolling and it's
hard to fight that out but yeah wait a
second let me watch that again bro and
kind of embrace the algorithm in a way
in a way
and linkedin you're on linkedin yeah i
am on linkedin yeah is that do you do
you like participate in linkedin because
you mentioned it a few times today uh so
i had it when i when i was uh getting
ready to transition out of the navy
because that's how i started reaching
out to people so yeah i have one of
those too yeah i have liked it too yeah
me too so we're on there uh echo you got
any final questions
that's it oh actually
um so do you think
and i i think this may seem like an
obvious answer but more so okay so when
you were growing up you know you had it
so many chores like it was like hard
right like so you got used to hard work
really
quickly yeah thoroughly essentially
could you feel that like as you know you
go through like you know hard things and
combat buds like all these hard things
or whatever and because you said you
said something kind of interesting where
you're like okay on the third time after
you got rolled or whatever the third
time you passed with no no issues you
said a lot of people like buds is like
real hard for them
did you feel that your work ethic that
was established
like was the factor that made it like a
non-issue like could you feel that at
the time
yeah absolutely um it was crazy
i thought about my my stepdad a lot
during whole week
because i thought about how hard he
worked i mean i mean the man worked
non-stop seven days a week two jobs and
i was going through hell week i thought
about him
i was like you know what if he can do
that i can do this right so that's how
i'm gonna provide for my myself and my
family
like
yeah
yeah that's what i was thinking when
you're saying that also it kind of makes
you reflect like
you reflect on like someone like your
childhood then i think man i should give
my kids more chores you know what's so
weird about buds is you just never know
who's gonna make it through you really
don't
and there's some silver spoon people
that go through there and crush it and
there's some silver spoon people that
wash out day two and there's some
freaking kids that grew up wherever in a
shitty situation working their ass off
and they quit yeah and there's some kids
like that that are awesome it's so
bizarre
it's very bizarre it's very hard to
predict there is some
like some
oh if the guy like they say if someone
wrestled it's a really good thing
because you have to work really hard in
wrestling that's a that's like an
indicator but it's by no means oh he
wrestled he's gonna make it not at all
not at all not even close yes one of the
many factors one of the many factors
might be a little nudge in the direction
of
but it's no guarantee crazy that's it no
good good to see you again yeah likewise
thank you for having me
any closing thoughts carlos
no not really just uh super grateful to
be here
grateful to be part of the the ef team
it's awesome being around team guys
again
always good man yeah awesome
all right well hey man thanks for
thanks for coming out today um obviously
thanks for your service and the teams
and thanks for what you're doing right
now to continue to share the lessons
that we learned uh to help people which
is what we're doing just doing our best
to help people i i
you have a great way of imparting the
messages um obviously it's great that
you can open up us to open up the
the tactics and the strategies and the
principles to a whole new audience
because you're a fluent spanish speaker
which is awesome it's been awesome to i
love watching those videos i'm like
because i i can understand a little bit
of spanish you know and because i took
three semesters of it when i was at
university of san diego
and so i can understand it i kind of get
the vibe you know but man it's freaking
cool to watch so
um yeah man it's great i appreciate it
and
[Music]
thanks for holding down
the tradition of the teams and thanks to
all the other frogmen out there still in
the teams still keeping the machine
rolling on
and upholding the standard set by our
forefathers
and thanks to all the military personnel
out there in every service for
protecting freedom around the world and
to our police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
emts dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service all other
first responders
including your wife carlos
thanks for protecting us here at home
and everybody else out there
the machine will roll on
the world's going to carry on without us
that's the reality it would be arrogant
to think otherwise
but at the same time
we can make a difference
you can help someone you can teach
someone
you can inspire someone you can make
your part of the world
a little bit better
and you do that
by going out there every day
and getting after it
and until next time
this is carlos and echo and jocko
out